ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS BATES
BELL FOR JUST BRADFORD
CABALLERO CHIANG DALLY DODD THE
RHIZOME GALGIANI GLAZER
GONZALEZ GROVE HERTZBERG HILL
HUESO TADO JACKSON JONES LATE
MCGUIRE. MELENDEZ MITCHELL
MONNING MORLOCK MORALE NIELSEN
PAN PORTANTINO ROTH RUBIO
SKINNER STERN BERG BY CASKEY
WIENER WELL. MEMBERS A QUORUM
IS PRESENT. WHAT THE MEMBERS.
GENTLEMAN YES. WHAT THE MEMBERS
AND OUR GUEST BEYOND THE REAL
IN THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE WILL
BE LE IMPROVE THIS AFTERNOON
BY SENATOR RUBIO AFTER WHICH
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING WILL BE
LED IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE
BY SENATOR STERN SENATOR RUBIO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. LOVING
GOD. MAKE ME AN INSTRUMENT OF
YOUR PEACE. WHERE THERE IS
HATRED LET ME SO LOVE WEATHER
IS INJURY. PARDON WHETHER IT'S
DISCORD HARMONY WHERE THERE IS
DOUBT EIGHT. WHERE THERE IS
DESPAIR HOPE WHERE THERE IS
DARKNESS LIGHT. AND WHETHER
IT'S SADNESS JOY- DIVINECREATOR GRAPHIC I MAY NOT SO
MUCH SEEK TO BE CONSOLED AS TO
CONSOLE TO BE UNDERSTOOD AS TO
UNDERSTAND TO BE LOVED AS TO
LOVE. FOR IT IS IN GIVING THAT
WE RECEIVE IT IS IN PARDONING
THAT WE ARE PARDONED AND IT IS
IN DYING. THAT WE ARE BORN TO A
TURN. AND. SH. THANK YOU
MEMBERS GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR
WILK FOR WHAT PURPOSE DO YOU
RISE. PRESIDENT I WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE A MOMENT OF SILENCE IN
HONOR TO MY CONSTITUENCY
RECENTLY PASSED WE HAD ROBERT
SINGLE FROM PALMDALE AND
KNOCKED HARSH FROM THE CITY OF
VICTORVILLE BOTH FOUND HUNG.
FROM A TREE. WHICH IS VERY ODD
SO. AND I WAS ON THE PHONE THIS
MORNING WITH- AGP SERRA AND
HE'S GOING TO BE CONDUCTING
ALONG SO LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
A FULL INVESTIGATION FOR THE TO
THESE FAMILIES IN OUR COMMUNITY
CAN HAVE CLOSURE BUT I'D LIKE
TO HONOR THE MEMORY OF THOSE
TWO MEN. ROBBER FULLER MALCOLM
HARSH THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR
WORLD MEMBERS PLEASE STAND AND
BY YOUR HEAD.
THANK YOU MEMBERS
CENTER HERTZBERG FOR WHAT
PURPOSE YOU RISE. LET ME THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT
FOR PURPOSES OF A DEMOCRATIC
CAUCUS AND GIVEN THE CHALLENGES
THAT WE'RE FACING WE ARE GOING
TO ADD I'M ASKING THAT EACH ONE
OF YOU. IN THE DAY OF THE
DEMOCRATS- TO RETURN YOUR
OFFICES WE PROVIDE YOU WITH THE
CALL IN NUMBER THE WEAKENED
SOCIALLY DISTANCE ARE CAUCUS
MEETING- AND WE'LL DO THAT NOW
THEY WILL RETURN TO THE FLOOR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. PRESIDENT.
OKAY BUT I'M SORRY SENATOR GROW
PURPOSE YOU RIGHT. AT FOR
PURPOSES CHANCERY. CAUCUS AT
WELL IN ROOM THREE OH FIVE.
THANK YOU THERE WILL BE A
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS AND THERE
WILL BE A REPUBLICAN CAUCUS WE
ARE IN. RECESS.
VETERANS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES SENATOR
MITCHELL FOR WHAT PURPOSE DO
YOU RISE. UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS PLEASE PROCEED
THANK YOU HAVE REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO TAKE UP
THE FOLLOWING BILLS WITHOUT
REFERENCE THE FILE AND THEY ARE
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY SIX.
EIGHTY FIVE AND SENATE BILL
SEVENTY FOUR. THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL. MEMBERS SEEING
SENATOR GROW IN CENTER GROVE I
THINK YOU YOU HAVE REMINDED ME
MEMBERS EACH OF YOU HAVE A
LITTLE I CALLED IT A FAMILY BUT
IS TO HELP GET THE PRESIDING
OFFICER'S ATTENTION SO IF I AM
NOT CALLING ON YOU PLEASE RAISE
YOUR FANS SENATOR GROW. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT REQUEST A
ROLL CALL VOTE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MADAM SECRETARY. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. IS IT GOING TO
BE ON MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
EXCERPTED OKAY. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I BATES. NO
WELL I FORGES NO BRADFORD BYE
BYE ADAM I CHIANG. DALLY NO
DODD HI TORONTO. HI GALGIANI. I
GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROWTH. NO
HERTZBERG I HILL. FIVE HUESO I
TADO. I JACKSON HI JONES NO
LEYVA AYE AYE MCGUIRE. I
MELINDA'S NO MITCHELL. I
MONNING I MORE LOCK NO MORALE.
NIELSEN NO HAN. I PORTANTINO I
ROTH. I RUBIO. I SKINNER. I
STERN. I I'M BURKE HI I LIKE
CASKEY. I WIENER FIVE WILK NO
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
CHIANG NO. MORRELL NO. FIVE
TWENTY NINE NEWS ELEVEN THE
MOTION CARRIES. SENATOR
MITCHELL. AB EIGHTY FIVE.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. FORGOT.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTY FIVE BY
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET AN ACT RELATING TO STATE
TAXES AND CHARGES AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET. THANK YOU SENATE
MITCHELL MADAM PRESIDENT I KNOW
YOU WERE TESTING ME I KNOW YOU
WERE TESTING ME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I APPRECIATE YOU- GOOD
AFTERNOON COLLEAGUES. ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHTY FIVE IS THE REVENUE
BUDGET TRAILER BILL. MOST
SIGNIFICANTLY THE BILL DOES THE
FOLLOWING THINGS THAT SUSPENDS
INCOME TAX NET OPERATING LOSS
DEDUCTIONS FOR TAXPAYERS WITH
INCOME OVER ONE MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THE TAXABLE YEARS BETWEEN
JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY AND
JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. IT LIMITS THE USE OF
ALLOWABLE TAX CREDITS TO OFFSET
CORPORATE AND PERSONAL INCOME
TAXES NO MORE THAN FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE TAXABLE YEARS
BETWEEN AGAIN JANUARY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWENTY IN JANUARY
ONE TWENTY TWENTY THREE. THE
BILL ALLOWS TAXPAYERS TO IN
FUTURE YEARS UTILIZED IN THE
NET OPERATING LOSSES OR TAX
CREDITS. THAT THEY ARE PROOF
THAT THEY ARE PREVENTED FROM
USING DURING THE NEXT THREE
YEARS AS A RESULT OF THIS BILL.
IT EXEMPTS EVERY LIMITED
PARTNERSHIP LIMITED LIABILITY
PARTNERSHIPS AND LIMITED
LIABILITY COMPANY IN ITS FIRST
TAXABLE YEAR FROM THE PAYMENT
OF THE ANNUAL MINIMUM FRANCHISE
TAX OF EIGHT HUNDRED DOLLARS.
CHOIRS USED CAR DEALERS TO RE
MET SALES TAX TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF MOTOR VEHICLES ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TAX AND FEE ADMINISTRATION TO
CLOSE THE EXISTING USED CAR
SALES TAX GAP. BILL COMPONENT
THE COMPONENTS OF THE BILL ARE
ESTIMATED TO INCREASE GENERAL
FUND REVENUE BY APPROXIMATELY
FOUR POINT FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS. IN THE BUDGET YEAR
MEMBERS I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND
OR DEBATE CENTER NIELSEN. MADAM
PRESIDENT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
THE SENATE TO FIRST I OBJECT TO
THE PROCESS. THERE'S BEEN NO
TIME THE DIGEST AND KNOW WHAT
THIS PARTICULAR DEAL MAY BE I
ASSUME THERE IS AN AGREEMENT
WITH THE MAJORITY AND THE
GOVERNOR. WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
THAT IS IT IS NOT BEFORE US.
ANOTHER CONSTRUCTIVE THAT THE
FIRST BILL WE BRING UP IS A TAX
INCREASE NOW THE NEW LEXICON IN
A- DEMOCRAT DICTIONARY IS
REVENUE. NOW THAT USED TO BE
CALLED TAXES AND I WILL
CONTINUE TO CALL IT WHAT IT IS
IT'S TAXES. THEY ARE TAX
INCREASES AS TO ONE OF THESE
IT'S TO ROLL OVER INTO THE
FUTURE AND YOU CAN ACCEPT THAT
NONE OF FUTURE BUDGET. THERE'S
NO HOPE THAT THAT CERTAINLY
WERE HAPPEN. BECAUSE JUST
LEGISLATURE HAS A- TERRIBLE
HABIT. AS DO GOVERNORS. BUT NOT
KEEPING THEIR WORD WITH THE
VOTERS. WE MAKE A DEAL IT GETS
RENEGED ON NEXT YEAR IT'S
HAPPENED AGAIN AND AGAIN AND A
DHL REGARDING TAX INCREASES.
AND A TAX INCREASE IN TAX
INCREASES PEARL OR NOT THE
WAYS. OUT OF OUR FISCAL
DIFFICULTIES TODAY. THERE ARE
SOME THINGS IN THIS BUDGET THAT
ARE DECENT AND CONSIDERATION
BUT NOTHING THAT'S GOING TO BE
SUSTAINING INTO THE FUTURE. NO
WE CAN COUNT ON THAT WILL KEEP
OUR BUDGET SOUND. AND BALLOTS
IN FACT EVEN DURING THE SO
CALLED FAT TIMES OF LATE. I'LL
ALWAYS ARGUED EVEN AT THAT
THERE ARE BUDGET WAS
PRECARIOUSLY BALANCED THE
CRISIS OF THIS YEAR ONLY OF
FIRMS THAT OBSERVATION. HOW
QUICKLY IT COULD GO BACK. IT IT
DID NEED TO BE OF THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF WHAT WE NOW ARE
SUFFERING. THE OTHER SIGNAL IS
TO THE BUSINESSES OF CALIFORNIA.
YOU'RE ALREADY TROUBLED. YOU'VE
NOT KNOWN WHETHER YOU'RE EVEN
GOING TO GET TO GO BACK IN
BUSINESS AGAIN TO OPEN YOUR
DOORS. AND AS EACH DAY PASSES
BY. MANY OF THEM GET CLOSER TO
THE POINT WHERE THEY WILL NOT
OPEN UP AGAIN. AND THERE'S
ALWAYS THE ASSUMPTION ORGAN
ONLY TAX RICH. YOU'RE ALREADY
THAT'S NEVER EVER BEEN SO.
CERTAINLY THERE AMPLY TAXED.
BUT KEEP IN MIND SOME OF WHO
THE RICH ARE. IN CALIFORNIA.
ALL THE ALL THE HIGH TECH
BILLIONAIRES. SURE BUT YOU KNOW
A LOT OF THEM ARE. COUPLE. WHO
SHOULD DRIVE AND START A
BUSINESS ON TO ME WILL TAKE
RISKS BLIGE THEMSELVES. BILL
THAT BUSINESS ORDER TO
PROFESSIONALS THAT ARE
SUCCEEDING IN THEIR PROFESSIONS.
AND HOW DO WE REWARD THEM
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN WE
INCREASE THEIR TAXES. AND THEN
THE QUESTION MUST BE. WHAT ARE
THE PEOPLE. RECEIVING THE EXTRA
TAXES. THE DAY IN COURT. THERE
ARE SOME INTERESTING P. Y.
INCREASES HERE IN THE BUDGET
PERSONNEL YEARS. AT SOME REALLY
DON'T MAKE ANY SENSE. LIKE
CONTINUING TO POUR MASSIVE
DOLLARS BEHIND HIGH SPEED RAIL.
AND ADDING ALLIES TO VARIOUS
AND SUNDRY AGENCIES. NOW A LOT
OF US HAVE HAD TROUBLE FOR
EXAMPLE. WITH THE UNEMPLOYMENT.
SITUATION IN CALIFORNIA. AND
THE DIFFICULTIES OF THE
DISASTER THIS BEFALLEN THE
CITIZENS BY THAT AGENCIES AND
COMPETENCE. SO WHAT DO WE DO I
THINK IT'S NOW SEVEN HUNDRED OR
SO NEW PERSONALITY IT WAS ONCE
A THOUSAND. THEY WERE GOING TO
GIVE THEM. NOW I WILL MAKE AN
EXAMPLE OF THIS TO THE-
REQUIRES GREATER SCRUTINY THAN
THIS HAS BEEN A LOUD. FOR YEARS
WE'VE HAD TROUBLE WITH THE ARM
FOR THE PERSON. CONFISCATION OF
WEAPONS THE FELONS HEAD STILL
IN THEIR POSITION. AND EACH
YEAR ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE
WOULD REQUEST MORE MILLIONS.
FOR MORE PERSONNEL. AND EACH
YEAR. THOSE PERSONNEL. DID NOT
GET HIRED. AND IN RESPONSE TO
WE WERE TOLD WELL WE CAN'T
COMPETE WITH PRIVATE ENTERPRISE.
OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENT FOR THE
ATTORNEYS WE NEED. THEY PAY
MORE. WHAT IS TO ASSURE US WITH
THESE PARTICULAR P. WISE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE. TO MAKE THE
UNEMPLOYMENT SITUATION IMPROVED
FOR OUR CONSTITUENTS WHERE ARE
THOSE SEVEN HUNDRED GOING TO
COME FROM. NOW THERE'S BEEN
SOME TRANSFERRED INTO CHICKEN
OR AGENCY WHAT WHAT DOES THAT
MEAN TO ANOTHER AGENCY. THE
POINT BEING THROUGH ALL OF OUR
TRIALS. PIECEWISE OF INCREASED.
ANOTHERONE OF THESE THAT WILL
BE INCREASING YET AGAIN
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION. WHAT AN IRONY
HERE SO MANY CALLS FOR
REALIGNMENT. AND THE DOWNSIZING.
AND EVEN IN THIS BUDGET TO
PRISONS WERE REPORTED TO BE
CLOSE. OR MAYBE ONE. AND THE
YOUTH AUTHORITY. PRETTY MUCH OF
ITS DOORS SHUT IT. WHAT DID WE
GET FOR THAT THE- AND THIS GOES
BACK ALMOST FIVE YEARS. THE
BUDGET THE CDC ARE DID NOT GO
DOWN IT WENT UP. AND ONE FORMER
SECRETARY AND I GIVE MUCH MORE
CREDIBLE. EIGHT INCH TO THE
CURRENT SECRETARY THAN THESE
PREVIOUS ONES. BUT I WAS TOLD
BECAUSE THE COURTS MADE US DO
IT. WELL I CAN GIVE YOU A LONG
DISSERTATION ABOUT THAT ISSUE.
SUFFICE TO SAY THERE WAS NO IF
YOU WILL PRESENT CLOSING
DIVIDEND. OR CDC ARE REFORM
DIVIDEND. IN FACT WHAT IT
HAPPENED WE JUST THROUGH OUR
PROBLEMS ON LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
SHOULD YOU DEAL WITH. IN FACT
THAT'S PARTLY WHAT WE'RE DOING
HERE WITH THE YOUTH AUTHORITY
NOW THERE'S SOME MONEY IN HERE
FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENT IN THIS
BUDGET. AND THAT'S GOOD THE
MOST OF US. WOULD NOT MIND THAT.
BUT IT SHOULD BE COUPLED WITH.
RELIEF FOR THE MANDATES ON
LOCAL GOVERNMENT. THE CLOSE IN
ON THIS PARTICULAR BILL. WE
HAVE NO IDEA WHERE THE REST OF
THIS BUDGET IS GOING TO GO. YET
WE'RE- FOR MORE REVENUE TO
START THE WHOLE DEBATE. MY FEAR
IS AS USUAL THAT'LL BE REVENUE.
GOES DOWN A DARK HOLE. IN
ANOTHER YEAR. WILL BE ON THE
PRECIPICE. OF ANOTHER DEFICIT
BECAUSE WE HAVE NOT DONE THE
JOB REQUIRED TO GET THIS BUDGET
LONG TERM MULTI YEAR UNDER
CONTROL I URGE A NO VOTE. THANK
YOU SENATOR NIELSEN CENTER
DOLLY. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MADAM RESIDENT IN MEMBERS I
WANNA JUST PREFACE THIS WITH I
AM IN A COMMENT ON THIS BILL IN.
SB SEVENTY FOUR SO THAT I WON'T
HAVE TO GET UP AND I HAVE
PREPARED MY COMMENTS FOR BOTH.
AND THAT WILL DO IT WHAT WITH
ONE. SENATE COMMENTS YOUR SITE
IS ONE OF THAT YOU KNOW THAT
THAT- IT'LL MAKE IT SO I DON'T
HAVE TO SPEAK AGAIN AND IT'LL-
SPEED THE PROCESS UP. THIS IS
THE MOST IMPORTANT VOTE. IT
WILL TAKE ALL YEAR THE BUDGET
BILL. THIS DETERMINES THE
PRIORITIES. OF WHERE CALIFORNIA
WILL GO IN THE NEXT YEAR.
THERE'S NO DOUBT ABOUT IT THE
COVE IT. HAS SET US BACK. HOW
FAR BACK. WE DON'T KNOW.
BECAUSE WE REALLY HAVEN'T HAD
REAL NUMBERS. THIS PROCESS HAS
ALLOWED US TO GET REAL NUMBERS
WE SURELY HAVE THE TIME WE EVEN
WORKED ON A SUNDAY I KNOW. BUT
WE SHOULD HAVE A CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE. THERE'S A GAME BEING
PLAYED. TO GET MORE MONEY FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. I'VE
ASKED SEVERAL TIMES IN THE
BUDGET COMMITTEES HOW MUCH ARE
WE GETTING FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. NO ONE CAN GIVE ME
AN ANSWER. HOW MANY MILLIONS OR
BILLIONS. THE QUESTION IS WHO
FUNDS THE GOVERNMENT WHETHER
IT'S STATE OR FEDERAL. WHERE
DOES THE MONEY COME FROM. WHO
PAYS TAXES. BEFORE WE CAN HIRE
ONE STATE EMPLOYEE. PRIVATE
BUSINESSES WILL THAT WORK FOR
THOSE BUSINESSES HAVE TO PAY A
TAX FIRST. SO BEFORE WE HAVE
HEALTHCARE IN HOME SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES A FIREFIGHTER A POLICE
OFFICER A SCHOOL TEACHER.
PRIVATE BUSINESSES AND PEOPLE
THAT WORK FOR THOSE BUSINESSES.
PAY TAXES FIRST. NOW TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE WE WERE IN A
RECESSION IF YOU'LL RECALL.
EVERY PASSED PROP THIRTY. TO
AVOID CUTS TO EDUCATION. IN.
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN. WE
EXTENDED THAT TAX WITH PROP
FIFTY FIVE WHICH ULTIMATELY
HELP CREATE A SURPLUS. AND WE
WERE GOING TO USE THIS BUDGET.
IT WE'RE GOING TO USE YOU DO
WITH THIS BUDGET IS WE'RE GONNA
CUT EDUCATION. ISN'T THAT WHY
WE SET UP A RAINY DAY FUND. NOW
WHAT ARE THE REAL PRIORITIES IN
THIS BUDGET. THE BUDGET WAS PUT
TOGETHER BY A SMALL GROUP OF
LEGISLATORS. HERE'S THE
PRIORITIES THAT I FOUND IN THIS
BUDGET. AB FIVE TWENTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS TO ENFORCE AB
FIVE. WHICH MEANS WE'RE GOING
TO WE'RE GOING AFTER BUSINESSES
AGAIN. BETTER PRESIDENT
PERMISSION TO READ. WITHOUT
OBJECTION THIS IS A LETTER.
FROM EDWIN LOMBARD WHOSE CEO OF
THE CALIFORNIA BLACK CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE ON THE FUTURE OF AB
FIVE. BLACK WHAT MAKES BLACK
FAMILIES AND BLACK BUSINESSES
HAVE BEEN DEVASTATED BY THE
TRIPLE. CATASTROPHES OF AB FIVE
COVERT NINETEEN AND VIOLENT
RACISM THAT PERMIT PERMEATES
THE VERY INSTITUTION WE ARE
RELY WE RELY ON TO PROTECT OUR
FREEDOMS AS AMERICANS. THE
BLACK MEN AND WOMEN WHO HAVE
CHOSEN TO WORK FOR THEMSELVES
WE'RE NOT ASKING FOR YOUR
PROTECTION. FROM SELF
EMPLOYMENT WE ARE NOT ASKING
FOR YOUR PERMISSION TO EARN A
LIVING AS WE CHOOSE. BY
STARTING A BUSINESS FOR
OURSELVES OR CONTROLLING OUR
OWN FUTURE AS INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS. WE ARE TIRED OF
THE. RITUALISTIC INSTITUTIONS
THAT PURPORT TO PROTECT US WELL
IN A BILLION DEPENDING. SEE
THREE. DEFENDING PROPAGATING
THE SYSTEMATIC RACISM THAT HAS
COST SO MANY BLACK LIVES AB
FIVE HAS ALREADY CRUSHED
THOUSANDS OF BLACK BUSINESSES
AND WE'LL KEEP MORE FROM
OPERATING IN THIS GIG ECONOMY
NEARLY A MILLION CALIFORNIANS
WOULD LOSE JOBS OPPORTUNITIES
AND INDEPENDENCE IF AB THE
FUTURE OF AB FIVE WERE UP TO
YOU. IF COOPER NINETEEN TAUGHT
US ANYTHING IT IS THAT PEOPLE
WHO LOST JOBS DURING THE
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN REALIZED.
THEY COULD WORK FROM HOME AS
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS. MAKE
MORE MONEY AND SPEND MORE TIME
WITH THEIR LOVED ONES. WE ARE
NOT ASKING FOR YOUR HELP OR
MISGUIDED PROTECTIONS JUST OPEN
THE DOOR AND LET US HELP
OURSELVES SINCERELY MR LOMBARDI
WHAT ELSE IS A PRIORITY IN THIS
BUDGET. WE'RE GONNA CREATE
SEVENTY NEW POSITIONS FOR THE
HIGH SPEED TRAIN IT TOWARD. WE
MAKE THESE CONTRACTORS STATE
EMPLOYEES A HUNDRED AND NINETY
ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS POSITION
THIRTEEN MILLION DOLLARS. LOOK
LET'S. NOT KID OURSELVES THE
HIGH SPEED TRAIN IS A
BOONDOGGLE. WE NEED TO CUT OUR
LOSSES AND MOVE ON BUT WE HAVE
WHAT WE USE THINGS THAT DO
BETTER THINGS FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT LIKE FUND CAL FIRE
AND FIRE SUPPRESSION. PUT MONEY
TOWARDS ROADS IT REALLY NEED
ATTENTION. WHAT ELSE IS A
PRIORITY IN THIS. BUDGET
ACTUALLY BILL WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT NOW IT'S REVENUE WHAT IS
REVENUE. REVENUE IS A TAX WHICH
I EXPLAINED EARLIER ON PRIVATE
PEOPLE AND BUSINESSES WHO PAY
THEIR TAX FIRST. REVENUE IS
SIMPLY ANOTHER NAME FOR A TAX
INCREASE NINE BILLION OVER
THREE YEARS FOUR POINT FOUR
BILLION THIS YEAR. LAST WE WERE
DOING LAST YEAR WE WERE DOING
JUST FINE BUT THIS YEAR THEY
ARE GOING TO SHOW A LOSS A LOSS
THIS THAT THE STATE WILL LET
THEM COUNT AGAINST THEIR TAXES.
THAT'S A TAX INCREASE ON
BUSINESSES ALREADY AFFECTED BY
COBIT. THE SAME PEOPLE THAT ARE
ALREADY PAID IN PROP THIRTY IN
PROP FIFTY FIVE. IT IS TIME WE
SHOW SOME RESPECT TO THESE
BUSINESSES. FOR THE BUSINESSES
AND THE WORKERS THAT PAY THE
BILL. ANOTHER PRIORITY IN THIS
BILL FIVE HUNDRED AND NINETY
SIX MILLION DOLLARS TO EXPAND
HEALTHCARE TO IMMIGRANTS HERE
ILLEGALLY. SIXTY FIVE MILLION.
TO EXPAND THE EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT TO IMMIGRANTS HERE
ILLEGAL. TEN MILLION IN
BUSINESS GRANTS FOR IMMIGRANTS
HERE ILLEGAL. WHAT ABOUT THE
BUSINESSES. THAT HAVE PLAYED BY
THE RULES THAT HAD TO SHUT
THEIR DOORS BECAUSE OF COVERT.
THAT HAVE BEEN PAYING FOR PROP
THIRTY PROP FIFTY FIVE. YOU
KNOW A COUPLE WEEKS AGO. THERE
WERE SOME TWEETS BACK AND FORTH.
ABOUT THE OWNER OF TESLA YVONNE
MASKUN PLACE TEN THOUSAND
PEOPLE THAT PAY TAXES IN
CALIFORNIA SO THAT WE CAN
PROVIDE SERVICES AND ONE OF THE
LEGISLATORS IN THIS FAMILY SAID
AB YOU YOU CAN GET OUT OF
CALIFORNIA. STOP THE PRIORITY.
THAT I THINK IS MISGUIDED
MEMBERS I LONG FOR THE DAY THAT
THE PEOPLE THAT ACTUALLY FUNDED
THIS GOVERNMENT GET THE RESPECT
FROM THE LEGISLATURE THEY
DESERVE. I HAVE A VISION OF A
DAY THAT WE SIT DOWN WITH REAL
FACTS. REAL NUMBERS REAL
SOLUTIONS. THIS PROCESS HAS
FAILED US. SOME OF YOU HAVE
BEEN TOLD YOU HAVE TO VOTE FOR
THIS BUDGET. ARE YOU REALLY
REPRESENTING THE MILLION PEOPLE
CONSTITUENTS IN YOUR DISTRICT.
FOUR FIVE PEOPLE HAVE SAT DOWN.
AND THEY WROTE THIS BUDGET
THEY'VE TAUGHT THEY'VE PICKED
WINNERS AND LOSERS IN YOUR
DISTRICT WITH PHONY NUMBERS. NO
WAY OUT I WOULD EVER SUPPORT
THIS BUDGET. FOR THE PROCESS.
AND YOU SHOULDN'T EITHER. I
URGE NO VOTE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR DOLLY SENATOR GROVE.
THEPRESIDENT I TO RISE IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS- BUDGET
TRAILER BILL- EIGHTY EIGHTY
FIVE AND- THE REASON WHY IS A
SIMILAR TO WHAT MY COLLEAGUE TO
SAID FROM BEAVER- WE NEED TO
UNDERSTAND CALLING SET THE
PRIVATE BUSINESS SECTOR PEOPLE
WHO PROVIDE PRIVATE JOBS ARE
THE ONLY SOURCE OF REVENUE NOW
SOME OF YOU MIGHT SAY I PAY
TAXES FOR MY EMPLOYEES IN THIS
BUILDING PAY TAX. BUT THE
ORIGINAL SOURCE OF THAT INCOME
COMES FROM THE PRIVATE BUSINESS
SECTOR WHEN YOU LOOK T OVER
68% OF THE REVENUE OR TAXES
THAT ARE GENERATED BY THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THAT FUND
GOVERNMENT IT COMES FROM
PERSONAL INCOME TAXES PAID FOR
BY THE PRIVATE SECTOR YOU GUYS
MIGHT ALL SAY WELL AGAIN I PAY
TAXES BUT THINK ABOUT THAT YOUR
ORIGINAL CHECK COMES FOR
PRIVATE BUSINESS. AGENCIES
MIGHT SAY WELL WE ONLY GET A
PORTION OF OUR MONEY FROM THE
GENERAL FUND BUT THE OTHER PART
OF THEIR MANY THAT IS GENERATED
IS GENERATED BECAUSE THEY SEE
THE PRIVATE SECTOR. FOR THIS TO
BE PRESENTED AS FIRST BUDGET
TRAILER TO BE TAXING TO IS ON
THE PRIDE SECTOR IS ACCEPTABLE
BECAUSE OF INTERSTATE HOME
ORDER BUSINESSES HAVE BEEN SHUT
DOWN ARE OPERATING AT A
DIMINISHED CAPACITY FOR THREE
AND A HALF MONTHS OR JUST OVER
THREE MONTHS THEY HAVEN'T HAD
THE ABILITY TO OPERATE FULLY
AND NOW THEY'RE GOING BACK
OPPORTUNITY DIDN'T CAPACITY
AND- NEW RIGHT TORY GOT.
SUBJECT TO KOBE NINETEEN. THESE
PEOPLE HAVE LAW A TON OF RED
EMPLOYEES HAVE LOST THEIR JOBS
AND WE NEED TO BE SUPPORTIVE
ABOUT BRINGING BACK THE PRIVATE
BUSINESS SECTOR IF WE CAN'T
HAVE A VIABLE AND OF A VIABLE
IN A SUCCESSFUL PRIVATE
BUSINESS SECTOR THERE IS NO WAY
WE'RE GOING TO GET OUT OF THIS
ECONOMIC SITUATION OF A FIFTY
FOUR BILLION DOLLAR DEFICIT
THAT WE FIND OURSELVES IN. THIS
YEAR THIS BILL SPECIFICALLY
SAYS HEY WE'LL GIVE YOU EIGHT
HUNDRED DOLLARS CREDIT FOR A
ONE YEAR US SECRETARY OF STATE
SERVICE FEE AND THAT WE'RE
GOING TO CHARGE YOU FOUR POINT
EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS THE FIRST
YEAR AND NINE BILLION DOLLARS
OF TOTAL OF THREE YEARS I THINK
ANY BUSINESS OWNER THAT HAS TO
BALANCE THE BUDGET RIGHT.
WITHOUT STEALING FROM SOMETHING
ELSE DIFFERENT POTS OF MONEY
BUT THEY ACTUALLY HAVE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY HAVE THE MONEY
IN THE BANK TO COVER THE BILLS
THAT THEY HAVE SET FORTH FOR
THE NEXT YEAR IN ORDER TO
OPERATE IN THIS STATE OR NATION
FOR ANY. FOR FACT. IF THEY
BALANCE THEIR BUDGET CORRECTLY
THEN THEY WILL KNOW THAT THEY
CAN EXCHANGE FOR EIGHT HUNDRED
DOLLARS SECRETARY IT TAKES
STATE TAX FILING IT'S
COMPLETELY A ROD DEAL. WHEN
YOU'RE GOING TO TRY TO CHARGE
THEM WITH THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION FOUR POINT. ALORS
OVER THREE YEARS. LET'S LOOK AT
THE- ISSUES THAT ARE FACING OUR
BUSINESSES WHICH WE VITALLY
NEEDED IN ORDER TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IN MAKING SURE
GOVERNMENT IS FUNDED. NOT ONLY
LIKE I SAID OF THE OPERATING A
DIMINISHED CAPACITY. OR
OPERATING NOT OPERATING AT ALL
AT THIS POINT FOR SOME OF OUR
BUSINESSES. THEY ARE RIGHT NOW
STRUGGLING WITH THESE
GUIDELINES IN THE LIABILITY
THAT THEY FACE SO EVEN IF THEY
OPEN AT A DIMINISHED CAPACITY.
THERE IS THE FEAR OF THE
LIABILITY EXPOSURE TO PAGO WITH
THESE TRIAL ATTORNEYS. THAT ARE
GOING TO RUN AROUND AND START
SUING EVERYBODY- REGARDING A
COVERT INFECTIONS OR ANY TYPE
OF OTHER ISSUE THAT'S GOING ON
IN OUR STATE. THIS BILL RIGHT
HERE TO DO IN EXCHANGE FOR A
SIMPLE EIGHT HUNDRED DOLLARS
OR- TO. CAP THE FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR TAX CREDIT WE CAN GO TO
THAT SUBJECT MATTER WE NEED A
LARGE BUSINESSES TO INVEST IN
OUR STATE. AND IF I WAS A LARGE
BUSINESS AND I OPERATED
ANYWHERE IN THE STATE IS IN
THIS NATION. AND I WANTED TO
INVEST I DON'T KNOW TWENTY
MILLION LET'S JUST CALL IT A
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
IN BUSINESS IS BUILDING. BUILT
IN MY BUSINESS AND BUILDING A
FACILITY A STRUCTURE REVAMPING
A STRUCTURE PUTTING IN NEW MANY
FACTS LINE FOR TRACK BRING THAT
FROM BECAUSE THAT. LESS WE
LEARN FROM NINETEEN THE CHINA
CONTROL EVERYTHING. OUR THE
THING WE WANT INVEST WE- TELL.
ONCE INVEST THAT MILLIONS OR
BILLION OF DOLLARS IN TO PRE
JOB IN THIS OF CALIFORNIA.
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE A CAP OF FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE TAX
CREDIT. WHY TO INVEST ALL OF
THAT MANY TO EMPLOY PEOPLE IN
THIS CALIFORNIA. TO PAY CASH.
THOSE WITH HIS IT THEN HAVE
JUST FIVE MILLION TEN CREEK A
PLOT. THERE'S NO WAY THEY'LL GO
TO ANOTHER STATE. WE
CALIFORNIAN STOP BEING SO HOT.
BUSINESS GOT. TO BE ABLE TO WE
URGE THEM TO WE'VE TO ENCOURAGE
TO GET THE TO BE AS YOU PULL SO
THAT THEY CAN EMPLOYEE AND
STATING GET EVERY OP. FOR
PEOPLE TO EMPLOYED IN PAID SO
THE WE CAN GOV BUT TO DO WHAT
WE'RE DOING IS THE FIRST BUDGET
BILL THAT COMES INTO THIS
BUILDING ON THIS SENATE SIDE IS
TAX INCREASES ON THE PRIVATE
BUSINESS SECTOR IS COMPLETELY
UNACCEPTABLE AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST A NO VOTE THANK YOU
SENATOR GROW. SENATOR MORLOCK.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT-
THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK ON. IN THIS PARTICULAR
BILL AB EIGHTY FIVE JUST A
COUPLE THOUGHTS ONE IS THAT
IT'S NICE THAT- WE ARE
EXEMPTING NEW NON CORPORATE
BUSINESSES FROM THE EIGHT
HUNDRED DOLLAR MINIMUM.
FRANCHISE TAX IT'S BEEN GOING
ON. LONG AS I'VE BEEN
PRACTICING- CORPORATIONS PAY
EIGHT HUNDRED DOLLARS A YEAR.
EVERY YEAR REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER THEY HAVE TAXABLE
INCOME ARE NOT. BUT IT'S
CERTAINLY SOMETHING WE
DISCUSSED- OVER TIME EVEN LAST
YEAR WITH THE BILL FROM.
SENATOR FROM PASADENA WHO TRIED
TO DO SOMETHING WITH THIS WITH
SMALL BUSINESSES. WE SHOULD RE
LOOK AT MAYBE EVEN ELIMINATING
IT ALL. JUST SO WE CAN
INCENTIVIZE BUSINESSES TO KEEP
MOVING FORWARD- THERE WOULD BE
A NICE GESTURE. THIS SOME THREE
YEAR SUSPENSION OF THAT ARE
BRING LOS DEDUCTION IS
SOMETHING I'D LIKE TO CHAT
ABOUT A LITTLE BIT SINCE I HAD
CLIENTS THAT HAD NET OPERATING
LOSSES AND- THEY'RE NOT
PLEASANT IT MEANS YOU. ACTUALLY
HAD TO GO INTO DEBT OR YOU.
REDUCE YOUR RESERVES
DRAMATICALLY TO. SUBSIDIZE A
TOUGH YEAR. AND SO YOU GET TO
CARRY THAT LAS BACK HOPEFULLY
GET A REFUND OR YOU CAN CARRY
IT FORWARD AND OFFSET FUTURE
REVENUES- IT'S A FAIR
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE STATE
AND BUSINESS OWNERS TO WORK
TOGETHER- DURING GOOD TIMES AND
IN BAD TIMES- BUT TO DEFERRED
FOR A FEW YEARS MANGER ASSUMING
THAT THE BUSINESS WILL STILL BE
IN BUSINESS FOR THREE OR MORE
YEARS- THAT'S NOT VERY
COMFORTING. THE THRESHOLD IS
ONE MILLION DOLLARS IN TOTAL
REVENUES THAT IS NOT A HIGH
THRESHOLD THAT. HERE ARE JUST A
SMALL CPA PRACTICE WITH A
PARTNER TO YOUR YOU'RE GONNA BE
OVER A MILLION DOLLARS IN GROSS
REVENUES AND FEES AND
BUILDINGS- SO IT'S GOING TO
CAPTURE A GOOD GOOD AMOUNT OF
OUR BUSINESSES HERE IN.
CALIFORNIA AND THAT THAT IS NOT
A GOOD GESTURE AS WERE TRYING
TO DIG OUT FROM CORONA VIRUS.
ALSO THE RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT CREDIT- WE SHOULD
BE REAL CAREFUL NOT TO ABUSE
THAT AND PUT THAT ON SUSPENSE
AS WELL. SO WHAT HAPPENS AND
IT'S ALREADY BEEN SAID AND I
WON'T BELABOR THE POINT BUT
WE'VE GOT TO WORRY ABOUT
MIGRATION OUT- IF WE MAKE THE
CLIMATE. TO HOSPITAL FOR GOOD
BUSINESS PEOPLE- THEY HAVE
OPTIONS AND THEY HAVE BEEN
TAKING THOSE OPTIONS AND WE
ARE. JUST TO HAVE TO LOOK AT
THE IRS MAILING ADDRESS CHANGES
OF WHO'S MOVED FROM CALIFORNIA
TO WHAT STATES AND VICE VERSA.
AND SO WE'RE SEEING A MIGRATION
TO STATES LIKE TEXAS AND-
NEVADA AND WE'VE GOT TO SOMEHOW
MAKE. EFFORTS TO. DECREASE AND
TURN THAT AROUND. SO MADAM
PRESIDENT IT'S GOING TO BE
DIFFICULT. BUT IF WE'RE GONNA
TAX A LITTLE BIT FOR EVERY
TIME. WE'RE NOT MAYBE MAKING
ENOUGH CUTS. THEN WE DON'T HAVE
FAR TO GO WITH WHAT WE'VE GOT
THE HIGHEST INCOME TAX RATES.
PROBABLY THE HIGHEST CORPORATE
RATES HIGHEST GAS TAX RATES
HIGHEST SALES TAX RATES WE WERE
IN WITH PROP THIRTEEN
IRONICALLY WERE ACTUALLY ALMOST
AT THE HIGHEST IN THE NATION OF
PROPERTY TAX RATES SO. WE DON'T
HAVE MUCH MORE ROOM TO PUSH SO
WITH THAT COLLEAGUES I WOULD
NOT RECOMMEND A NO VOTE ON AB
EIGHTY FIVE THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SENATOR
MORLOCK CENTREBOARD JUST. THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT. I WON'T
BELABOR SOME OF THE POINTS THAT
MY COLLEAGUES HAVE ALREADY MADE.
BUT I THINK MY BIGGEST CONCERN
WITH WHAT WE'RE DOING TODAY IS
THAT THERE IS A PROCESS PROBLEM.
IN THE PROCESS PROBLEMS IS. WE
ARE MOVING ON BUDGET ITEMS AND
WE DON'T UNDERSTAND THE CONTEXT
OF. IN WHICH WE'RE OPERATING
WHAT I WILL BE MORE SPECIFIC IF
YOU WERE TO GO TO A BANK FOR A
LOAN OR IF YOU WERE TO HAVE
OTHER FINANCIAL ARRANGEMENTS
AND ANY NUMBER OF INDUSTRIES.
THE INDIVIDUALS THAT WOULD BE
ASSISTING YOU WOULD NATURALLY
ASK WHAT IS YOUR REPAYMENT PLAN.
NATURALLY WHAT IS YOUR BUSINESS
PLAN FOR SUCCESS- GETS
COMMONSENSICAL ENQUIRIES ON
WHETHER OR NOT WHAT YOU'RE
PURSUING IS FISCALLY PRUDENT.
MY ISSUE HERE IS. WE ARE MOVING
FORWARD WITH OUT A STATE PLAN.
AND I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
THE GOVERNOR AND THE RESPECTIVE
LEADERS IN BOTH HOUSES THAT. WE
SHOULD BE LOOKING AT THE
TRAILER BILLS IN THE LARGER
BUDGET WITHIN OUR ECONOMIC
RECOVERY AGENDA OF CALIFORNIA.
OTHER SHOULD BE THREE THINGS
THAT WE SHOULD BE LOOKING AT-
AS LAWMAKERS AND IDEALLY FROM
FOLKS IN THE EXECUTIVE SIDE OF
THINGS. WHAT IS OUR ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT PLAN TO GET US OUT
OF OUR IMPENDING DIFFICULTIES.
TWO WHAT ARE THE EXPECTED
OVERHEAD CUTS THAT ARE GOING TO
ALLOW US TO MOVE FORWARD OF
COURSE THREE WOULD BE THE TAX
DISCUSSION. WITHOUT IN ECONOMIC
RECOVERY PLAN. THAT INCLUDES
THESE THREE ITEMS WE ARE
CERTAINLY PUTTING THE CART
BEFORE THE HORSE. NOW IF YOU'RE
ASKING FOR NINE BILLION DOLLARS
IN TAX INCREASES WHERE S THE
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT PART OF
THE PLAN. WHERE ARE THE CUTS
THAT WOULD NATURALLY BE
EXPECTED IF WE'RE GOING TO
MANAGE A FIFTY FOUR BILLION
DOLLAR SHORTFALL. SO COLLEAGUES.
I WILL GET INTO EVERYTHING THAT
WAS DISCUSSED PRIOR TO MY
COMMENTS HERE BUT SHOULDN'T WE
BE ASKING THE GOVERNOR FOR IN
ECONOMIC RECOVERY PLAN.
SHOULDN'T WE BE ASKING OR
LEADERS IN BOTH THE SENATE IN
THE ASSEMBLY. NOT JUST BE THE
BIG THREE BUT THE BIG FIVE. TO
MAKE CERTAIN THAT ALL THE
VOICES THAT ARE RELEVANT IN THE
PROCESS FOR AT LEAST ALLOWED TO
PARTICIPATE. BECAUSE AS IT
STANDS RIGHT NOW WE RE
THROWING MONEY AT A PROBLEM WE
DON'T FULLY UNDERSTAND. AND I
THINK TO DO TO DO IT IN THIS
FASHION IS FISCALLY IMPRUDENT
IT'S NOT SMART IT CERTAINLY NOT
RESPONSIBLE IN WE CAN DO THINGS
BETTER. I'M NOT ASKING I THINK
FOR A LOT BUT IT IN ECONOMIC
RECOVERY PLAN. IS ESSENTIAL FOR
US NOT JUST IN THIS BUDGET BUT
FOR THE FORESEEABLE FUTURE
BECAUSE TO MAKE DECISIONS
WITHOUT IT I THINK IT'S JUST
TOSSING MONEY WITHOUT-
COMMENSURATE CUTS IN ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT STIMULUS- IN MIND.
THANK YOU SENATOR BORDERS
SENATOR HERTZBERG. THANK YOU
WERE SENATE PRESIDENT WAS
INTENDING TO SPEAK BUT I WAS
LISTENING CLOSELY. TWO ARMED
OUR COLLEAGUES ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE AISLE. AND I WANTED
TO RESPOND I THINK CONTEXTUAL
E. AS TO WHERE WE ARE. AS TO
WHAT WE'VE DONE HISTORICALLY
AND WE'RE CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA'S ABOUT YOU GOT MY
ATTENTION. FIRST AND FOREMOST
IN NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT THE
GDP IN CALIFORNIA JUST LOOKED
UP WAS ONE POINT FOUR TRILLION
THANK. IN TWO THOUSAND TEN ONE
POINT NINE TRILLION IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN TWO POINT
NINE TRILLION AND TODAY. THREE
POINT TWO TRILLION DOLLARS. SO
WE'RE DOING SOMETHING RIGHT AT
SOME LEVEL. THE QUESTION.
NUMBER TWO IS THERE'S NO DOUBT
THAT IT'S FAIR TO SAY THAT'S
THIS REVENUE COMES FROM
BUSINESSES NO QUESTION. BUT
THERE IS A STRUCTURAL PROBLEM
IN CALIFORNIA IN A RICH POOR
DIVIDE. WHERE WE HAVE THESE
EXTRAORDINARY NUMBERS AND
PEOPLE LIKE TO TALK ABOUT THE
SIZE OF OUR ECONOMY COMPARED TO
OTHER GLOBAL ECONOMIES. BUT
THERE'S A VERY SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGE WE HAVE SOME OF THE
POOREST FOLKS WHO WERE
CHALLENGE TO THE GREATEST LEVEL
AND WE HAVE SOME OF THE
COMPANIES THAT ARE THE MOST
DYNAMIC AND THE RICHEST. WHICH
INFORMS OUR THREE POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLAR GDP. IT SHOWS WE
SIT DOWN AND BE RESPONSIBLE AND
THOUGHTFUL LEADERS WITH RESPECT
TO CRAFTING A BUDGET. THE
QUESTION IS HOW DO YOU DO IT
NOW I THINK IT WAS NINETEEN
NINETY TWO WHEN PETE WILSON CUT
A DEAL WITH JERRY BROWN THAT
WOULD JERRY BROWN WITH PETE
WITH A- WILLIE BROWN. AND ARE
YOUNGER BROTHER. A END TO THEY
DID SAY BILL IN CUTS SEVEN IN
INTACT. IF YOU TAKE A LOOK AT
THE LARGE MARKETS. WE DON'T
KNOW. WHAT WHAT THE FEDERAL
GONNA DO UNDER. BUT WE DO KNOW
THAT THE STATE CAN. HAS A
PRETTY HAD A PRETTY HEALTHY.
ETHICS RATE A FUN THAT WAS
SUPPLEMENTED BY RAINY DAY FUND
FOR SOCIAL SPECIAL SIR I MEAN
FOR SAFETY NET SUPPLEMENTED BY
A FURTHER. A SAFETY NET FOR
EDUCATION ALL OF WHICH HELPS
CREATE A LARGER DYNAMIC. AS WE
MOVE INTO THE NEXT TO FACE
AFTER WE GET PAST THIS BUDGET.
AND START THINKING ABOUT WHAT
ECONOMIC RECOVERY LOOKS LIKE IN
A RESPONSIBLE WAY THAT WILL
ATTRACT. BUSINESS AND THE LIKE.
I THINK THAT. IT'S IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND OVER A PERIOD OF
TIME AS WE HAVE SOUGHT. TO
CRAFT BUDGETS WHY THIS APPROACH
IS SO INTELLIGENT. BECAUSE WHAT
HAPPENS IS WOULD YOU LIKE IT OR
NOT WHEN YOU CUT SERVICES TO
FOLKS. YOU DON'T ELIMINATE THE
NEED PEOPLE ARE STILL HUNGRY
THIS DOING TO BE HOUSE YOU SO
ABOUT THE SORTS OF PROBLEMS.
YOU CAN'T. TAKE A BUDGET AND
JUST OBLITERATED AND JUST CUT
EVERYWHERE EVERY DOLLAR AFFECTS
HUMAN BEINGS AND HUMAN LIFE A
ROOF OVER SOMEBODY'S HEAD NICHE
CATION FOOD IN THEIR MOUTH.
BECAUSE OF THE EXTRAORDINARY.
WHICH PORT DIVIDE THAT WE HAVE
IN CALIFORNIA SO I THINK THAT
ALTHOUGH THIS THERE IS THIS
ISSUE WITH RESPECT TO LOSS
CARRY FORWARDS IN THE SCHEME OF
THINGS. WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
LARGE DYNAMIC OF WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH HOW WE'RE
TRYING TO BE THOUGHTFUL AND
CONSERVATIVE ON THE ONE HAND
BUT YET NOT BECAUSE A WHOLE
HOST OF FOLKS FOLKS BRICK
PROBLEMS. THAT YOU LOOK WHERE
WE'VE GROWN WHERE WE'RE GOING
AND WHAT WE NEED TO BE DOING
FOR ECONOMIC RECOVERY IN MY
JUDGMENT. I AM IMPRESSED BY
THIS BUDGET. I AM IMPRESSED BY
THE COOPERATION BETWEEN THE TWO
HOUSES IN TERMS OF. THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE DIGNITY OF
THE LEGISLATIVE BRANCH OF
GOVERNMENT AND I'M PROUD OF
THAT WORK. AND SO I STAND IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BUDGET.
AND I JUST YOU KNOW I AGAIN I
WANT TO SHOW RESPECT TO ALL
OPINIONS BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
OUR JOB IS EVERYBODY HAS
DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES THEY
REPRESENT. BUT I THINK IF YOU
LOOK AT IT IN THE BIG PICTURE.
THIS REALLY IS AN APPROPRIATE
THOUGHTFUL APPROACH AN EXTRA
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
CENTER HERTZBERG SENATOR PAN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT NOW
MAYBE IT'S BETTER IF WE JUST.
SIT MICROSCOPE TOO HIGH SO I'M-
CAN I WANT TO- SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF EIGHTY EIGHTY FIVE. LIKE ALL
BUDGET ITEMS ESPECIALLY DURING
A DEFICIT- I KNOW THAT MANY OF
US MAY NOT NECESSARILY BE
THRILLED TO VOTE FOR SOME OF
THE ITEMS BUT AGAIN BUDGET
MAKING IS ABOUT PRIORITIES AND
CERTAINLY REMEMBER. BEING HERE
WITH- MANY OF MY- GOOD FRIENDS
HERE- IN HOME WE CAME INTO THE
LEGISLATURE SOME BEFORE. TWENTY
TEN WHEN I CAME IN SOME OF. MY
GOOD FRIENDS- HERE ALSO CAME AT
THE SAME TIME WE HAD A TWENTY
EIGHT BILLION DOLLAR DEFICIT
AND- WE HAD TO MAKE VERY HARD
CHOICES. BUT I ALSO WANT TO
MAKE NOTE AS WE APPROACH- NOT
ONLY THIS BILL BUT THE OVERALL
BUDGET. AS MY GOOD FRIEND FROM
LOS ANGELES- MENTIONED.
ACTUALLY CALIFORNIA- PRIOR TO
CALVET NINETEEN. WAS ACTUALLY-
DESPITE. THE TAX INCREASES THE
VOTERS PASS ON COUPLE DIFFERENT
OCCASIONS WHICH GOT US OUT OF
OUR LAST HOLE- DESPITE. OTHER
THINGS THAT PEOPLE OF CRITIQUE
IS BEING- BAD FOR OUR ECONOMY
ACTUALLY HAD A CONDOM ME THAT
GREW FASTER THAN MOST OF THE
REST OF THE COUNTRY. WE CREATED
MORE JOBS THAN MOST THE REST OF
THE COUNTRY- AND SO. IN FACT
CALIFORNIA OVERTOOK NOT ONLY
OTHER STATES BUT OTHER
COUNTRIES AROUND THE WORLD IN
TURN DECIDES OF OUR ECONOMY.
AND SO OVERALL I THINK WE HAVE
TO RECOGNIZE THAT CALIFORNIA
WAS AND ECONOMIC SUCCESS OVER
THE PAST DECADE DOESN'T MEAN
THAT WE DIDN'T- HAVE PROBLEMS
AND I THINK IT WAS NOTED ALSO
BY. A GOOD FRIEND FROM LOS
ANGELES WE ALSO HAVE TREMENDOUS
WEALTH DISPARITIES. BEFORE
CODED WE WERE TRYING TO DEAL
WITH ISSUES AROUND. HOUSING
LACK OF HOUSING. OTHER TYPES OF
NEEDS THAT- THAT WERE THERE. AS
WELL AND THEN CERTAINLY
COVERAGE SHOWED UP. NOW I WOULD
KEEP IN MIND THAT WE HAVE THIS
FIFTY FOUR BILLION DOLLARS THE
ADMINISTRATION ESTIMATING ARE
ELLIE IS A LITTLE DIFFERENT-
DEFICIT BECAUSE- OF A-
INFECTION THAT. NOT NOT ONLY
LEAD TO A GOVERNMENT ACTIONS
BUT ACTUALLY BECAUSE PEOPLE
RECOGNIZE THAT IT WAS DANGEROUS
TO GO OUTSIDE TO CHANGE
PEOPLE'S BEHAVIORS. EIGHT N.
FACT WE'VE LOST OVER- A HUNDRED
THOUSAND AMERICANS BECAUSE OF
IT I THINK WE'RE APPROACHING
FIVE THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS
STEAD. EVEN THOUGH WE'VE DONE A
MUCH BETTER JOB THAN MOST OF
THE REST OF THIS COUNTRY IN
ADDRESSING THIS IN FACT IF WE
WANT TO TRY TO UNDO- WHAT'S
HAPPENED WITH BECAUSE OF IT.
OUR FIRST PRIORITY NEEDS TO BE
SURE WEEK CONTAINING CONTROL
THIS INFECTION SO I CERTAINLY
HOPE THAT ALL OF. THE PEOPLE
HERE WHO HAVE SAID THAT. WHAT
THE PRIORITIES OF COURSE IS TO
GET OUR ECONOMY GOING THINK ALL
OF US HERE THAT THAT WE WOULD
BE VIGOROUS ADVOCATES FOR
SCIENCE BASED INTERVENTIONS. TO
ADDRESS COLLUDED WITH SUCH AS
WEARING MASKS TELLING PEOPLE TO
PHYSICALLY DISTANCE. ARE THOSE
ARE TWO THINGS. THAT ARE
NECESSARY TO PREVENT FURTHER
SPREAD OF THE DISEASE THAT WILL
THEN ACTUALLY DISCOURAGE
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY. THE OTHER
THING I'D ALSO POINT OUT IS
THAT ECONOMIES ARE. BY CONSUMER
SPENDING. AN ALMOST BUSINESS.
AND I KNOW THAT WITHOUT
CUSTOMERS MY BUSINESS WOULD NOT
BE ABLE ARE ALWAYS MY WAIST
BUSINESS WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
SURVIVE. AND SO WHEN WE THINK
ABOUT HOW WE WANT TO STIMULATE
THE ECONOMY. WE ALSO HAVE TO
THINK ABOUT. THE CUSTOMERS. SO
WHO ARE THE CUSTOMERS WELL MANY
OF THE CUSTOMERS ARE PEOPLE WHO
ACTUALLY GET STATE ASSISTANCE.
THEY'RE A SPENDING ACTUALLY
DRIVES ECONOMIC ACTIVITY FOR
OTHER BUSINESS FOR BUSINESSES
TO SUCCEED SO. CERTAINLY WON'T
DISAGREE THAT PRIVATE BUSINESS
IS A VERY IMPORTANT SOURCE. OF
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY BUT WE ALSO
RECOGNIZE THAT CONSUMER.
ACTIVITY IS SOMETHING THAT IS
ACTUALLY GENERALLY APPROX
ESTIMATE ABOUT TWO THIRDS OF
OUR ECONOMIC TV IN THE UNITED
STATES IS DRIVEN BY CONSUMER
ACTIVITY. AND SO WE HAVE TO
THINK ABOUT AS WE CRAFTER
BUDGET HOW DO WE SUPPORT PEOPLE
IN A WAY THAT NOT ONLY OF
COURSE. WE WANT TO. ENSURE THAT
THEY CAN LIVE IN DIGNITY THAT
THEY ARE NOT IN NEED OF BASIC
NECESSITIES. BUT ALSO THAT
THEY'RE IN A POSITION TO ALSO
CONTRIBUTE TO OUR ECONOMY IT'S
pCONSUMERS. AND SO I THINK WE
ARE WE HAVE TO HAVE DIFFERENT
PRIORITIES- THERE CERTAINLY
WHEN LOOKING AT THIS PARTICULAR
BILL AROUND REVENUES. OTHER
PRICE THING I WOULDN'T MIND
PERSONALLY MAKING SOME
ADJUSTMENTS TO BUT OVERALL.
CERTAINLY I WOULD BE IN SUPPORT
AND URGE PEOPLE TO VOTE FOR.
THIS BILL EIGHTY EIGHTY FIVE AS-
BASICALLY IT APPROACH TO BE
SURE THAT WE CAN STRIKE AN
APPROPRIATE BALANCE BUDGET.
THAT WILL HELP SUSTAIN THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA AND TAKE A
STEP TOWARD RESTORING
CONTINUING OUR ECONOMY IN THE
FACE OF A DEADLY PANDEMIC WHICH
WE STILL NEED TO CONTINUE TO
ADDRESS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR PAN SENATOR WIENER.
THANK YOU- MADAM PRESIDENT I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB. EIGHTY
FIVE OH IS NOT INTENDED AS BUT
I DID WANNA SINCE THE DRESS ONE
ISSUE THERE BEEN SOME COMMON.
ABOUT CAN. WHO ARE NOT-
DOCUMENTS. AND SOMEHOW
SUPPOSEDLY TAKING RESOURCES
WITHOUT GIVING WITHOUT
CONTRIBUTING AT WHICH IS
ABSOLUTELY- FALSE- WE KNOW
THAT. ARE UNDOCUMENTED
NEIGHBORS HERE AND AROUND THE
COUNTRY ARE NOT SAYS HANG OUT
HERE THEY ARE WORKING. THEY'RE
PAYING TAXES THEY'RE STARTING
RUNNING SMALL BUSINESSES AND
THEY ARE NOT CONTRIBUTORS- TO
OUR ECONOMY AND OUR STATE- AND
FEDERAL RESPONSE TO COVERED. BY
JUST COMPLETELY SLICE AL AND
THEY ARE STRUGGLING LIKE
EVERYONE ELSE AND WE SHOULD BE
SUPPORTING ALL. CALIFORNIANS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
WIENER SERVER MELINDA. ON AGAIN
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM I
JUST WANTED TO MAKE COMMENT
RELATING TO THE STATEMENTS THAT
WERE BY OUR CALL IN SO. TALK
ABOUT. THE PHONE WHO WERE IN ON
OUR SYSTEMS AND THAT SOME OF
THEM YOU KNOW ARE SUBSIDIZED BY
THE GOVERNMENT AND IT IS VERY
IMPORTANT. THAT WE ARE THERE
FOR THEM I WOULD LIKE TO REMIND
EVERYONE THAT THE MONEY THAT
IS. SPENT ON HELPING THOSE
INDIVIDUALS COMES FROM. THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY AND THE
TAXPAYERS IN WITHOUT THEM
WITHOUT THEM RIDING WITHOUT
THEM BEING ABLE TO BE
SUCCESSFUL AND CONTINUE. KEEP
THEIR DOORS OPEN THERE WILL BE
NO SUBSIDY FOR ANYONE. BEAR
CODE. SAID JUST WANNA MAKE THAT
DISTINCTION WHEN WE WHEN WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT THE PHILANTHROPIC
EFFORTS AT THIS LEGISLATURE AND
HOW WE SPEND OUR MONEY. BUT
THAT MONEY DOES COME FROM
SOMEONE. AND THAT SOMEONE NEEDS
OUR HELP TO NOT JUST CERTAIN
SEGMENTS OF THE POPULATION
BECAUSE WITHOUT THAT BUSINESS
COMMUNITY. WE NOTHING TO SPEND-
I WOULD URGE IN ABOUT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU CENTER MELINDA'S
SENATOR DOLLY. THANK YOU MADAM.
PRESIDENT OF MY COLLEAGUES SAID
I THOUGHT YOU WERE TO SPEAK
ONCE I HEARD YOU. BUT I WANT TO
JUST RESPOND TO MY GOOD FRIEND
FROM SAN FRANCISCO. LOOK
THERE'S NO DEBATE ON THE FACT
THAT UNDOCUMENTED PEOPLE.
CONTRIBUTE TO OUR ECONOMY.
THAT'S NOT WHAT I'M SAYING. I
AGREE WITH YOU THAT THEY PAY A
TAX AND THEY THEY'RE PART OF
OUR SYSTEM AND THEY AND THEY
THEY DO PROVIDE THINGS WE NEED
BUT THEY ALSO WHAT ABOUT THE%
HEALTH CARE WE PROVIDE NOBODY'S
DONE THE CALCULATIONS OR IS
ABLE TO GIVE US A REAL NUMBER
ON HOW MUCH IS PAID IN. AND HOW
MUCH IS PAID OUT SO WE NEED TO
BE ABLE TO HAVE APPLES TO
APPLES COMPARISONS ON THIS
DEBATE. BUT WHAT MY COMMENT WAS
WAS THAT. THE BUSINESSES THAT
ARE LEGITIMATELY BEEN WORKING
FOR GENERATIONS HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED BY KOBE. CAN YOU RUN
THE BRINK RIGHT NOW OF MAYBE
NOT STAYING IN BUSINESS ANY
LONGER. NEED A BREAK. THEY NEED
SOME HELP DON'T DON'T TAKE AND
PUT A TAX ON THEM THIS BILL
DOES THAT. HI BUT LET'S LOOK AT
THOSE FOLKS WHO. CONSISTENTLY
HELPED OUR ECONOMY GROW TO THIS
THREE POINT TWO TRILLION
DOLLARS. THAT WAS MY POINT I
DON'T DISAGREE WITH YOU THAT
THEY DO ADDED ECONOMY BUT THEY
ALSO TAKE FROM OUR ECONOMY AND
WE NEED REAL NUMBERS WHAT ARE
WE PAYING. TOO UNDOCUMENTED
THAT ARE USING OUR HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM WE DON'T HAVE THAT
NUMBER. IS WHEN YOU GO TO THE
EMERGENCY ROOM YOU GET SERVICE.
NO MATTER WHERE YOU'RE FROM. IF
YOU'RE IN CALIFORNIA SO I JUST
WANTED TO MAKE THAT POINT CLEAR.
THANK YOU CENTER DOLLY SENATOR
BATES. MY ARE NOW I AM. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK MEMBER OF AND I DO NOT
BELIEVE I WOULD BUT THERE'S
JUST A LITTLE FACTOID IN ALL OF
THIS THE DISTURBS ME ON AND NOW
HAS TO DO WITH OUR EMPLOYEES WE
HAVE AN INCREDIBLE INCREDIBLE
WILL NEED FOR. INSURANCE WHY
SETTLE FACT BECAUSE IN PLACE
THERE ARE EMPLOYERS THERE
AREN'T JOBS SO THIS SEEMS TO BE
AN UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE OF
THIS ISSUE TAXING OR TAKING
REVENUES FROM OUR BUSINESSES
THAT ARE TRYING TO SURVIVE THE
SURVIVOR THE SURVIVAL OF
BUSINESSES SURVIVAL OF AN
EMPLOYEE AND HIS INCOME TO HIS
FAMILY AND CERTAINLY TO- WHAT
HE CONTRIBUTES TO THE COMMUNITY
IN TERMS OF GOODS AND SERVICES.
SO IT JUST SEEMS ALMOST-
INTELLECTUALLY. DATEABLE THAT
YOU CAN TAX OF BUSINESS IN
STEEL KEEP BILL THERE ARE SO P.
HAVE A PLACE TO SO I WOULD ASK
WE CONSIDER THAT WITH THIS VOTE
I WOULD YOU KNOW VOTE ON FOR
THE AND OF. WHO ARE CURRENTLY
ON OF JOB BECAUSE THE
BUSINESSES CAN NO LONGER
SUSTAIN THEM THANK YOU THANK
YOU SENATOR. BATES SENATOR
GROVE. MADAM PRESIDENT JUST ONE
FINAL ON A APOLOGIZE FOR THIS
TIME I KNOW WERE LOOKING AT A
TIME SCHEDULE BUT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO REALIZE THAT WITH
FOUR POINT EIGHT MILLION PEOPLE
UNEMPLOYED BECAUSE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S I'M STAY AT HOME
ORDER. WE AGAIN NEED PRIVATE
BUSINESS TO BE ABLE TO PULL
EMPLOYED. I ALSO WANT TO
ADDRESS THE ONE MILLION DOLLAR
CAP IN BUSINESS- IN THE TAXES
THAT ARE IN THIS PARTICULAR
PIECE OF LEGISLATION. WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT IT A MILLION
DOLLARS IS NOT HARD TO ACHIEVE
IF YOU ARE BILLING OUT AND HAVE
A BUSINESS. SO TO LIMIT THAT
AND ESPECIALLY THAT'S GROSS
REVENUES. THAT IS A GROSS
REVENUES MEANING YOU BILL OUT
AND MILLION DOLLARS AND THAT'S
GOING TO BE THE CAP ON YOUR TAX
STRUCTURE RIGHT THERE YOUR
INCOME STRUCTURE. THAT YOU'LL
BE ABLE TO LIMIT. THAT DOES NOT
MEAN THAT OUT OF THAT MILLION
DOLLARS YOU DON'T PAY PAYROLL
PAYROLL TAXES RENT I MEAN IF
YOU THINK IF YOU HAVE A NICE
BUILDING IN A DECENT PLACE FOR
YOUR BUSINESS IT'S TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS A MONTH RENT THAT'S A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS. FOR
THAT MILLION DOLLARS SO NOW
YOU'RE DOWN TO NINE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS. IN YOUR TO
READ BUT GROSSED ONE MALE. DO
YOU HAVE FOR CAPITAL IN PAYROLL
TO FIGHT YOU TO SEE DVD WORKERS
COMP LIKE BILL INSURANCE OF
THAT STUFF. PLUS OTHER INSURE.
YOUR PROBABLY DOWN TO HUNDRED
DOLLAR AND NOW HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS OF NET RED. THEN YOU
ADD A TIME P. G. OF LIKE. FEEL
THE HIT BEEN FOR EMPLOYEE. THAT
MILLION DISAPPEAR VERY QUICK SO
NOW YOU'RE DOWN TO ABOUT THE
SIXTY THOUSAND IN ACT NECK.
READ THAT SHE HAVE IN ORDER TO
KEEP TO INVEST OPERATING YOUR
BUSINESS AS A SMALL BUSINESS
OWNER. NOW WHEN THIS BILL
PASSES YOU'RE GOING TO PAY
TAXES ON THAT MILLION DOLLARS.
OUT OF THE MONEY YOU HAVE LEFT
AFTER YOU'VE PAID FOR EVERY
THING ELSE. IT'S NOT FEASIBLE
AND IT DOESN'T WORK AS A
BUSINESS OWNER IT DOES. WORK SO
MANY CAR NEEDED GEN LEDGER LOOK
AT THE EXPENSE IS NOT A THAT
GENERAL READ. WERE YOUR- YOUR
GROSS READ. ENDING YOU DID ALL
THE G. IN A COST. OPERATING
EXPENSES AND THEN HAVE TO PAY
TAXES ON A GROSS REVENUE NUMBER
THAT'S LIMITED OUT A MILLION
DOLLARS. IS GOING TO EAT UP ANY
AMOUNT THAT YOU HAVE LESS PLUS.
YOU'LL MOST LIKELY HAVE TO
BORROW TO PAY THE TAXES BECAUSE
OF THIS BILL. WE NEED THE
PRIVATE SECTOR TO SUCCEED. TO
PAY FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE CONSUMERS THAT GO INTO
BUSINESSES TO PURCHASE STAFF
ESPECIALLY IF THEY'RE ON
SUBSISTENCE ARE A- LIMITED
INCOME. AND WE NEED TO BE ABLE
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY SURVIVE.
AGAIN DEALING WITH KOBE
NINETEEN THE ISSUES THE MORE
REGULATORY PROCESSES IT THEY
HAVE IN PLACE. THE NEW
GUIDELINES OPERATING AGAIN A
DIMINISHED CAPACITY AND NOT A
FULL FORCE. THIS IS SO
IMPORTANT THAT WE DON'T PASS A
BILL THAT INCREASES TAXES ON
OUR PRIVATE BUSINESS SECTOR
WHICH GENERATES ALL THE MONEY.
THAT WE HAVE IN THIS BUILDING
TO OPERATE ON INTO DISTRIBUTE
OUT HOW THIS LEGISLATIVE BODY
SEES FIT I AM RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NO THE- THANK YOU SENATOR
GROWTH. MA'AM SEEING NO FOR TO.
OR DEBATE. SENATOR MITCHELL
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. MADAM
PRESIDENT I WOULD OUGHT WHILE I
APPRECIATE THE CHALLENGE OF OUR-
SOCIAL DISTANCING IN ALL I
WOULD STRONGLY ENCOURAGE FOR
THE NEXT SEVERAL BUDGET BILLS
THAT WE FOCUS OUR TESTIMONY ON
THE ISSUE AT HAND. ON I THINK
THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL FOR US
ALL TO FALLEN BE CLEAR WHAT
YOU'RE BEING ASKED TO VOTE ON-
I THINK THE CONVERSATION THE
DEBATE GOT SO EXPANSIVE I WANT
TO JUST MAKE SURE PEOPLE ARE
CLEAR WHAT'S ACTUALLY IN AB AT
FOUGHT. THERE WILL BE PLENTY OF
OPPORTUNITY FOR PEOPLE TO STAND
UP THE PRESIDENT RECOGNIZED
PEOPLE MORE THAN ONCE SO IF WE
COULD FOCUS OUR TESTIMONY THE
BILL AT HAND WHICH IS CUSTOMARY.
WHEN WE PROVIDE SOME
CLARIFICATION I'M NOT GONNA
JUST THE BUDGET AS A WHOLE
THAT'S NOT THE BILL BEFORE US
I'M GONNA TALK ABOUT A. B.
EIGHTY FIVE AND WHAT'S ACTUALLY
IN IT. THIS BILL RAISES
APPROXIMATELY FOUR POINT FOUR
BILLION IN HAS BEEN PART. A KEY
PART OF THE BUDGET FRAMEWORK
SINCE THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISE. AND INCLUDED. IN THE
SENATE VERSION OF THE BUDGET.
NUMBER TWO THE TWO COMPONENTS
THE NET OPERATING LOSS
SUSPENSION IN THE FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR TAX CREDIT CAP. DEBT
REYES MOST OF THE REVENUE OF
THE FOUR POINT FOUR BILLION.
LET'S BE CLEAR THEY ARE
ACTUALLY DELAYS OF WHEN SOMEONE
CAN UTILIZE THESE TAX BENEFITS.
NOT TAX INCREASES. THREE WHO'S
IMPACTED WE RECOGNIZE THAT
EVERYONE IS HURTING THAT WE
TALKABOUT THAT CONSISTENTLY
INCLUDING BUSINESS HOWEVER TO
BE IMPACTED BY THE NET
OPERATING LOSS PROVISIONS OF
THIS BILL YOU WOULD NEED TO
HAVE INCOME OF ONE MILLION
DOLLARS OR MORE IN WHICH TO
OFFSET LOSSES AGAINST. FOR THE
TAX CREDIT CAP WANTING TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ESTIMATES
GENERALLY A CORPORATION WOULD
NEED TO HAVE INCOME OF OVER
FIFTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS TO BE
AFFECTED ON A PERSONAL INCOME
TAX PAYER WOULD NEED TO HAVE
INCOME OVER FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THAT'S THE WHO.
LET'S BE CLEAR THE BUDGET THAT
WILL COME BEFORE US WILL STILL
CONTAIN CUTS. CUTS INCLUDING
THIS BUDGET OF THE TRIGGER CUTS
WILL IMPACT UCC ISSUE THE
COURTS. AB STATE WORKER
COMPENSATION REDUCTIONS. ALSO
SIGNIFICANT SUSPENSIONS BUILT
FROM THE CURRENT YEAR BUDGET
AGREEMENT THAT WILL CUT WELL
OVER ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
FROM PROP FIFTY SIX IN IT
ASSESS AND SO AS WE TALK ABOUT
WHAT IT WILL TAKE. THE CONTINUE.
TO PROPEL CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY
FORWARD WE HAVE TO CREATE A
SENSE OF BALANCE. FOR ALL THOSE
REASONS ONCE AGAIN I WILL ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE ON THISTRAILER
BILL AB EIGHTY FIVE. THANK YOU
SENATOR MITCHELL MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA OR AYE ATKINS
I BATES NO BELL I FORGES NO
BRADFORD I HAVE A- I CHIANG. NO
DALLY NO DODD. I THERE ARE SO.
I GALGIANI. I GLAZER I GONZALEZ
I GROWTH. NO HERTZBERG I HILL.
I HUESO HI I TADA. JACKSON I
JONES. NO LEYVA AYE AYE MCGUIRE
AYE MELENDEZ. NO MITCHELL HI
MONNING FIVE WARLOCK NO MORALE.
NO NIELSEN. NO HAN I PORTANTINO
I ROTH. I RUBIO. I SKINNER. I
STERN I AM VERY. WHITE HOUSE
SKI I WIENER I WILK RIGHT NOW.
PLEASE CALL THE OF THE MEMBERS
ONE MORE TIME TADO. I'M BURKE.
EYES TWENTY SEVEN NEWS ELEVEN
THE MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WE
ARE MOVING ON TO FIVE AB
SEVENTY SIX MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTY SIX BY THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AN ACT
RELATING TO EDUCATION FINANCE
AND MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BILL REALLY DIDN'T
RELATED TO THE BUDGET. SENATOR
MITCHELL THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AB SEVENTY SIX OF OUR
EDUCATION TRAILER BILL AND
CONTAIN STATUTORY CHANGES TO
IMPLEMENT THE TWENTY TWENTY
BUDGET THAT. THE BILL THE FIRST
ONE POINT NINE BILLION IN PROP
NINETY EIGHT PAYMENTS FOR K.
THROUGH TWELVE EDUCATION FROM
JUNE TWENTY TWENTY TWO JULY
TWENTY TWENTY N. DIFFERS THREE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY MILLION IN
PAYMENT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES FOR MAY AND
JUNE TWENTY TWENTY. TO DO JULY
TWENTY TWENTY. THESE DEFERRALS
REDUCE APPORTIONMENT FOR THE
PROP NINETY EIGHT TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY GUARANTEE AND
INSTEAD COUNTIES APPORTIONMENT
FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE PROP NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE. IT APPROPRIATE FOR
MORE THAN SIX POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN PROP NINETY
EIGHT SUBTLE OF FUNDING FOR THE
L. C. F. F. IN THE TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY FISCAL
YEAR I ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR MAY MEMBER
DISCUSS AND OR DEBATE. VERY
GOOD CENTER NIELSEN PRIEST
PLEASE MADAM PRESIDENT LADIES
DOWN THE CENTER LIKE NOT HAVE
ANY OBJECTION TO THIS BILL IN
FACT MANY OF US VOTED FOR IT
ALREADY. AND IT DOES HELP.
EDUCATION AT ALL LEVELS WE ALL
AGREE THAT IS A PRIORITY AND
PANTS ARE FAVORABLE VOTES ON IT.
BUT I WILL SUBMIT. THERE'S
LITTLE IN THE BILL AND IT WILL
INSURE AN IMPROVING EDUCATION.
AN IMPROVING QUALITY OF
EDUCATION AFFORDED TO OUR YOUTH
FACE AN ABSOLUTELY UNCERTAIN
FUTURE AS TO WHAT KIND OF
EDUCATION THEY'RE GOING TO GET.
IS IT ALL GOING TO BE ON LINE
IS A NOW SO CLUMSILY IS BEING
COMMITTED TO THEIR- FUTURE. I
SURELY HOPE NOT. WE DON'T KNOW
THAT BUT THAT SAID THOSE
BATTLES TO BE FOUGHT ANOTHER
DAY THIS IS WORTHY OF AN AYE
VOTE I URGE AND I WILL. THANK
YOU SENATOR NIELSEN MEMBERS ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
CENTER MITCHELL VERY GOOD MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. FIVE ARCHULETA I ATKINS
I BATES I TELL. FIVE FOUR. I
BRADFORD I HAVE A YELLOW I
CHIANG I DOLLY. FIVE DODD. I TO
WRESTLE. I GALGIANI I GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROW. I HERTZBERG I
HILL I LISTEN ON I- TADO I
JACKSON I JONES I LEYVA HI I
MCGUIRE. I MELINDA'S I MITCHELL.
I MONNING I WARLOCK I MORALE. I
NIELSEN. I PAN I PORTANTINO. I
ROTH I RUBIO. I SKINNER I STERN
HI I'M BURKE I WHITE HOUSE
STEVE. I WIENER. I WILK AYE
AYES FORTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
OF. MEMBERS THERE ARE NO
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM
THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED
READ REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL
BE DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE FOLLOWING BILLS
WITH FLOOR AMENDMENTS WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED FILE ITEM FIFTY NINE
SENATE BILL NINE SEVENTY TWO.
WILL GO TO THE FLOOR NO
OBJECTION VERY GOOD. WE WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO CONSIDERATION OF
THE DAILY FILE AGAIN AND WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO SECOND READING.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION AT
FIFTY NINE AND ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTY FIVE. SECOND READING
WILL BE DEEMED READ THANK YOU
MA'AM SECRETARY. MEMBERS WE ARE
WAITING ON SB SEVENTY FOUR TO
COME TO US FROM THE ASSEMBLY SO
FOR EVERYONE WILL JUST. STAY IN
PLACE AND- RELAX WILL LET YOU
KNOW ON A RAID PROCEED. DON'T
LEAVE.
MEMBERS AGAIN PLEASE DO
NOT LEAVE THE FLOOR WE ARE
GOING TO START DOING SOME BILLS
WE'RE GOING TO PUT TOGETHER A
LITTLE LIST AND WE'RE GOING TO
GET STARTED SO WE CAN BE
PRODUCTIVE WHILE WE'RE WAITING.
PART MEMBERS IF YOU CAN PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEATS WE'RE GOING TO
HEAR SOME BILLS. START WITH
FILE ITEM SIXTY NINE SENATOR
UMBERG MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL ELEVEN FORTY
SIX BY SENATOR UMBERG AN ACTUAL
LEADING TO CIVIL PROCEDURE
SENATOR UMBERG. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES. MEMBERS
OF THE SENATE SB ELEVEN FORTY
SIX HELPS ADDRESS SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT- CIVIL
LITIGATORS AND COURTS ARE
FACING WITH RESPECT TO CIVIL
LITIGATION- IN THE MRS KOBE
CRISIS WHAT IT DOES IS IT IT
PROVIDES THAT ONCE YOUR STATION
AS A STAB WISH THAT. EACH SIDE
CONSERVE ONE ANOTHER
ELECTRONICALLY IT CUTS DOWN THE
TIME EXPENSE AND HASSLE OF
SERVICE PROCESS THE OTHER
PROVISION ALLOWS FOR ELECTRONIC
DEPOSITIONS AND IN THE COURSE
LOOKED LIKE THE POSITION THAT
THE PERSON THE- DEPOSING
OFFICER TYPICALLY THE COURT
REPORTER NEED NOT BE PHYSICALLY
PRESENT TO ADMINISTER THE OATH
THE WORDS THE DEPOSITION BE
TAKEN WITH THE COURT REPORTER
AT ANOTHER LOCATION
ADMINISTERING THE SIMPLE BILL
IT'S CO SPONSOR BY BOTH. CAN
CONSUME ATTORNEY REGION I VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER AMBERG MEMBER
ANY DOES. AND TO BE. SEEING AS
HEARING. MEMBERS IS ANY OF TO
YOU A YOU KNOW ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING THEM I IS
FOR KNOWS TO MAY PASS. WE'RE
GOING TO. WHAT A PAUSE FOR A
MOMENT.
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE BACK TO FILE ITEM SIXTY
EIGHT BY SENATOR MORALE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL TWELVE SEVENTY ONE BY
SENATOR MORAL AN ACTUAL LEADING
TO PROFESSIONS AND VOCATIONS.
SEVERAL THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS- TODAY
I'M HERE TO PRESENT SB TWELVE
SEVENTY ONE IN TWO THOUSAND AND
FOURTEEN AB SIXTEEN OH EIGHT
ALLOWED THE BUREAU OF SECURITY
AND INVESTIGATIVE SERVICES. TO
AUTHORIZE LICENSED PRIVATE
INVESTIGATORS TO BE ORGANIZED
AS LIMITED LIABILITY COMPANIES
THIS IS THE SECOND SUNSET
EXTENSION. SINCE AB SIXTEEN OH
EIGHT WAS IN ACTED S. B. TWELVE
SEVENTY ONE MOVES A SUNSET DATE
FROM JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TO JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. THERE'S
BEEN NO REPORTS RECEIVED OF
INSURANCE CLAIMS SINCE THE LAST
SUNSET EXTENSION AND THERE'S NO
REST REGISTERED OPPOSITION IS
BILL AND NO NO VOTES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE PLEASE THANK YOU CENTER
MORAL MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. EYES
FORTY TWO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES.
MEMBERS WE HAVE
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY
MADAM SECRETARY READ WHEN YOU
ARE READY. MADAM PRESIDENT I AM
DIRECTED TO INFORM YOUR
HONORABLE BODY THAT THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDED AND ON THIS
DAY PASSED ADOPTED AS AMENDED
SB SEVENTY FOUR. AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR HONOR
FOR HONORABLE BODY TO CONCUR IN
SAID AMENDMENTS TO PARKER CHIEF
CLERK OF THE ASSEMBLY ABOVE THE
BILL ORDER TO UNFINISHED
BUSINESS FILE. THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY SENATOR MITCHELL ARE
YOU READY. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SB SEVENTY FOUR.
SENATE BILL SEVENTY FOUR BY
SENATOR MITCHELL AND AFTER
LEADING TO THE STATE BUDGET TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BUDGET
BILL. SENATOR MITCHELL MADAM
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO MUCH
WHAT A DIFFERENCE SEVERAL
MONTHS MAKES. IT WOULD NEVER
HAVE OCCURRED TO ANY OF US IN
JANUARY. THAT TO ALL OF YOUR
BRIGHT IDEAS ABOUT INVESTMENTS
IN YOUR DISTRICTS WOULD NOT BE
INCLUDED IN THIS BILL. ITNEVER
OCCURRED TO ANY OF US IN
JANUARY THAT WE'D BE STAND HERE
WITH LITTLE SHOWER CAPS ON OUR
MICROPHONES AND MATH. AND SOME
OF YOU BEHIND PLEXIGLASS.
TRYING TO DEBATE THE PEOPLE'S
BUDGET AND YET HERE WE STAND.
SB SEVENTY FOR THE BUDGET BILL
FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
FISCAL YEAR. THIS BILL IS THE
RESULT OF HARD WORK OVER THIS
PAST MONTH IN THE MIDST OF
GRAPPLING WITH. A PUBLIC HEALTH
AND ECONOMIC. WORLDWIDE
PANDEMIC THAT IS CHANGED ALL OF
OUR LIVES. BECAUSE OF THE
CURRENT PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS
CALIFORNIA NOW FACES A FIFTY
FOUR BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET
SHORTFALL AS WE APPROACH THE
NEW FISCAL YEAR. THE BUDGET WE
ARE PASSING TODAY REPRESENTS A
TWO PARTY DEAL BETWEEN THE
SENATE IN THE ASSEMBLY.
ALTHOUGH WE ARE WORKING HARD TO
OBTAIN A THREE PARTY DEAL THAT
INCLUDES THE ADMINISTRATION
TODAY WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PASS A BUDGET THAT STANDS ON
ITS OWN. IN MEETING OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL DEADLINE FOR
PASSING A BALANCED BUDGET BY
JUNE FIFTEENTH. THIS
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET AGREEMENT
CLOSES THE FIFTY FOUR BILLION
DOLLAR BUDGET SHORTFALL BY
FOLLOWING THE SAME REASONABLE
FRAMEWORK SET FORTH IN THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION. WITH A
MIX OF SPENDING REDUCTIONS.
TEMPORARY NEW REVENUES
BORROWING DEFERRALS EXISTING
FEDERAL FUNDS USED RESERVE AN
ANTICIPATED ADDITIONAL FEDERAL
FUNDS. THE LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
AGREEMENT ALSO INCLUDES A
TRIGGER COMPONENT SHOULD THE
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL FUNDS NOT
MATERIALIZE. THIS TRIGGER
ESTABLISHES SOLUTIONS THAT
WOULD NOT GO INTO EFFECT UNTIL
OCTOBER FIRST IF THE ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL FUNDS DO NOT COME IN.
THESE TRIGGER SOLUTIONS INCLUDE
THE USE OF ADDITIONAL RESERVES
AND DEFERRALS AS A MEANS TO
MINIMIZE PROGRAMMATIC
REDUCTIONS. WE LEARNED IT TOUGH
LESSONS DURING THE LAST
DOWNTURN AND CUTS TO PROGRAMS
THAT ARE STATES VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS DEPEND UPON
OFTENTIMES EXACERBATE THE
PROBLEMS WE ARE TRYING TO
ADDRESS AND TAKE PRECIOUS TIME
EFFORT AND RESOURCES TO RESTORE
THE PRIOR LEVELS. WE SPENT
YEARS BUDGETING RESPONSIBILITY
AND BUILDING A SIGNIFICANT
RESERVE SPECIFICALLY TO AVOID
THE PAINFUL ACTIONS THAT WE
WERE FORCED TO TAKE DURING THE
GREAT RECESSION. AND ALTHOUGH
NONE OF US ANTICIPATED THAT WE
WOULD BE FACING A FISCAL CRISIS
IS UNIQUE AND SEVERE AS WE ARE
CURRENTLY FACING UTILIZING
RESERVES AND OTHER TOOLS AT OUR
DISPOSAL IN ORDER TO MINIMIZE
REDUCTION TO CRITICAL PROGRAMS
IS THE RESPONSIBLE THING AS
POLICY MAKERS TO DO. WITH THAT
SAID I WANT TO NOTE THAT THIS
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET AGREEMENT
WITH IN THE BUDGET YEAR WITH
MORE RESERVES OVER ELEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS. IN THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVIVE SHOULD WE
RECEIVE ADDITIONAL FEDERAL
FUNDS. THIS WILL INCLUDE THE
MAINTENANCE OF OVER HALF OF THE
MANDATORY DEPOSITS TO THE RAINY
DAY FUND. AND ALL OF THE SAFETY
NET RESERVE. IF THE ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL FUNDS DO NOT
MATERIALIZE AND THE TRIGGER
SOLUTIONS GOING TO AFFECT. WE
WOULD STILL IN THE BUDGET YEAR
WITH HALF OF THE MANDATORY
BALANCE OF THE RAINY DAY FUND
AND TOLL RESERVES OF
APPROXIMATING SEVEN POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS. THE
CONSTITUTION PROVIDES TWO KEY
DEADLINE REQUIREMENTS FOR THE
ANNUAL STATE BUDGET. ONE IT
REQUIRES THE GOVERNOR TO
PRESENT HIS BUDGET BY JANUARY
TENTH EVERY YEAR. AND SECOND IT%
REQUIRES THE LEGISLATURE TO
PASS A BALANCED BUDGET BY JUNE
FIFTEENTH. NOTHING IN THE
CONSTITUTION REQUIRES THE
GOVERNOR THE ONLY PRESENT A
BUDGET THAT THE LEGISLATURE
AGREES TO. AND SIMILARLY
NOTHING IN THE CONSTITUTION
REQUIRES THE LEGISLATURE TO
ONLY PASS A BUDGET THAT THE
GOVERNOR HAS CONCURRED IN. AND
JUST AS THE GOVERNOR MET HIS
CONSTITUTIONAL OBLIGATION ON
JANUARY TENTH TODAY THE
LEGISLATURE MEETS ITS
CONSTITUTIONAL OBLIGATION BY.
HEARING AND HOPEFULLY PASSING
THIS RESPONSIBLE BALANCE AND
THOUGHTFUL BUDGET THEY CLOSES
THE FIFTY FOUR BILLION DOLLAR
SHORTFALL AND KEEPS
CALIFORNIA'S FINANCES IN SOUND
CONDITION. WITH THAT MADAM
PRESIDENT I ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL SENATOR ATKINS. MADAM
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
COLLEAGUES. LET ME JOIN THE
BUDGET CHAIR AS I POINT OUT
THAT THIS BUDGET IS ROOTED IN
RESPONSIBILITY AND IT WAS
CREATED WITH COLLABORATION AT
ITS CORE. THE RESULT IS A PLAN
THAT IS RESPONSIVE TO THE
ECONOMIC REALITY THAT
CALIFORNIA FACES AS A RESULT OF
COVERT NINETEEN. AND IT
PROTECTS THE PROGRAMS THE
RESOURCES AND THE SAFETY NETS
THAT SO MANY WORKING FAMILIES.
RELY UPON AND NOW WILL RELY
UPON EVEN MORE. WE ENTERED THISPROCESS WOULD LEGISLATIVE
BUDGET PRIORITIES BETTER
FAITHFUL TO THE PRAGMATIC
FISCAL STRUCTURE. AS THE BUDGET
CHAIRED NOTED THAT WAS PUT
FORTH BY GOVERNOR NEWSOME IN
HIS MAY REVISION. TOGETHER WE
HAVE CRAFTED A BUDGET THAT NOT
ONLY CLOSES A FIFTY FOUR
BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET GAP. BUT
AVOIDS THOSE DRACONIAN CUTS.
AND PROVIDE STRONG FOOTING AS
CALIFORNIA EXPERIENCES
CHALLENGING ECONOMIC TIMES THIS
PLAN WILL PROTECT QUE FOR
TWELVE AND HIGHER EDUCATION IT
DOES OVER HEALTH CARE COST
INCREASES FOR SENIORS. AND CUTS
TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROGRAMS
THAT ACCOUNTS FOR THE ONGOING
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING PROCESS
REGARDING COMPENSATION FOR OUR
STATE'S PUBLIC EMPLOYEES. MANY
THAT WE ARE GOING TO COUNT ON
IN THIS VERY DIFFICULT TIME TO
PROVIDE THOSE SAFETY NET
SERVICES. OVER THE PAST DECADE
WE'VE WORKED HARD TO BE IN A
POSITION TO WEATHER. JUST SUCH
A STORM. THIS BUDGET ENABLES US
TO WHETHER IT RESPONSIBLY AND
WITH PRECISION. SO THAT WE
AVOID WREAKING FURTHER HAVOC ON
CALIFORNIANS LIVES. TODAY AS
OUR BUDGET CHAIR POINTED OUT WE
MEET OUR CONSTITUTIONAL
OBLIGATION TO PASS A BALANCED
RESPONSIBLE BUDGET BY JUNE
FIFTEENTH. JUST AS THE GOVERNOR
HAS MET HIS CONSTITUTIONAL AND
STATUTORY OBLIGATION TO PRESENT
A BUDGET. TO US THE LEGISLATURE.
I JUST AS WE DIDN'T AGREE WITH
EVERY DETAIL OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL HE HAS NOT YET AGREED
TO EVERY DETAIL OF THE BUDGET
THE LEGISLATURE IS PASSING
TODAY. TO THE QUESTION OF WHAT
COMES NEXT WE CONTINUE TO MEET
WITH THE GOVERNOR AND HIS STAFF
AND NEGOTIATIONS ARE ONGOING.
FATHER WILL BE CHANGES TO
REFLECT THE FINAL AGREEMENT. WE
WILL NOT DEVIATE FROM THE
PRINCIPLES THAT WE HAVE
OUTLINED IN THIS BUDGET. NOW
THAT WE HAVE BOTH MET OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL REQUIREMENTS
IT'S TIME FOR THE GOVERNOR AND
THE LEGISLATURE TO COME
TOGETHER AND MEET OUR MORAL
OBLIGATION AND REACH A FINAL
BUDGET AGREEMENT. IN TIME FOR
THE START OF THE FISCAL NEW
YEAR. FORTUNATELY I DO BELIEVE
THE GOVERNOR SHARES THESE
VALUES AND THAT WE WILL ALL BE
CONTINUING THE HARD WORK TO
FIND AN AGREEMENT THANK YOU.
MADAM PRESIDENT THANK YOU
SENATOR ATKINS THE SENATOR
NIELSEN. PRESIDENT LAYS DOWN
WITH THE SENATE YOU. I WANT A
COP ALL MEMBERS OF THIS
HONORABLE BODY. AS WE'VE
LISTENED TO OUR DISCUSSIONS AND
DEBATE HERE THUS FAR. IT
TYPIFIES THE WAY THE SENATE
WORKS. RESPECTFUL WITH DIGNITY
THOROUGHNESS. AND YES INDEED
WITH PASSION ON THINGS THAT WE
BELIEVE IT. AS TO THE BUDGET
I'M THANK YOU GLAD THAT THERE'S
BEEN DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
GOVERNOR. I WONDER WHAT IT BE
THAT HE MIGHT BE TELL THIS
PARTICULAR BUDGET. THE OTHER
WILL BE FOLLOWING TRAILER BILL
SAID IMPLEMENTED AND- THAT KIND
OF DRAGS OUT. THE BUDGET AS AND
WHEN WILL THERE BE A BUDGET. WE
LEAVE HERE TODAY NOT AND
GLEEFUL THAT WE COMPLETED OUR
TASK. WITH ONLY MADE. A COUPLE
OF STEPS. I ARGUE THAT THEY ARE
STEPS IN THE WRONG DIRECTION.
AND IN FACT THE BUDGET PROCESS.
AND YOU'LL EXCUSE ME BUT I'VE
TAKEN THE CALL IT NOT A PROCESS
BUT A SCRUM. BUT IT PLAY RUGBY
THEY DID PLAY FOOTBALL. I PLAY
THE LINE AND WHEN YOU START A
PLATE IT'S ALL OF THIS
SHUFFLING AND TING AND- NOT
REALLY NECESSARILY ALWAYS
GETTING ANYWHERE A STRONG. THAT
MORE TO ME DESCRIBES WHAT ARE
BUDGET HAS DEVOLVED INTO WHERE
WE'RE AT TODAY. AND IN THIS
PARTICULAR BUDGET. REPUBLICANS
WERE NOT INVOLVED. WHEN WE DO
HAVE A CONFERENCE COMMITTEE AT
LEAST THERE'S AT OPPORTUNE FOR.
TO EXPRESS OPINIONS TO EXERCISE
THE DO SCRUTINY AND OVERSIGHT
THAT IS THE MISSION OF THE
SENATE. AND WHOEVER PREVAILS
PREVAILS. BUT IF YOU REMEMBER
THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN ON THESE
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEES AND THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE ITSELF. WE
NEVER LOCKSTEP BOAT. RARELY
EVER. AND THAT'S A GOOD PART OF
THE PROCESS. NOW OVER THE YEARS
THE CONFERENCE COMMITTEE IS IN
ONE PLACE WHERE THERE COULD BE
SOME BART BY PARTISAN
DISCUSSION NEGOTIATION. EVEN
SOME INPUT WITH THE GOVERNOR.
HERE IN GERMAN. THAT HAS BEEN
UTTERLY LACKING. EACH OF US
REPRESENT ONE MILLION PEOPLE.
AND I WOULD ARGUE. BY VIRTUE OF
CUTTING OUT. THE REPUBLICANS
FROM DISCUSSIONS AND
NEGOTIATIONS. THE CARD IT
CUTTING OUT A MILLION PEOPLE
THAT WE REPRESENT. FROM THEIR
VOICES BEING HEARD JEWELERS.
THEY SHOULD BE AWARE OF THAT
THAT THEY ARE BEING DENIED THE
POSITION OF OPPORTUNITY TO
CHANGE THINGS. THE OTHER ALL
WISH REFORMS THAT YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SEE I REFERRED TO THE
LACK OF REFORMS IN THE
EDUCATIONAL PORTION OF THE
BUDGET WE JUST VOTED FOR. IT
WOULD HAVE BEEN WELL IF THERE
HAD BEEN SOME. AND I KNOW THAT
THERE ARE SOME IN THIS BUDGET
AT LEAST IS WHAT I KNOW AT THIS
MOMENT. OUR REFORMS FORMALLY
DONE THAT ARE BEEN ROLLED BACK
TO SOME DEGREE. AND THERE ARE
SOME PROVISIONS IN HERE THAT
ARE ARGUABLY GOOD REFORMS FOR
THE FUTURE. THAT COULD WORK
WARRANT AND ENJOY BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT. NOT THE TAX THE
BUSINESS THAT IS NOT A REFORM.
AND SOME SEEM TO THINK THAT ANY
TIME THAT YOU IF TAXES TO NEW
MANTRA HERE. IF YOU GIVE ANY
MONEY BACK. TO THE CITIZENS OR
LEAVE BUSINESS OR CITIZENS OF A
TAX BURDEN. THAT THAT IS A GIFT
OF PUBLIC FUNDS. WHICH IS
SUPPOSED TO BE ILLEGAL WE
SHOULD NOT MAKE A GIFT OF
PUBLIC FUNDS BUT I THINK THAT
IS AN ABSURDITY. WHERE THE MAD
HATTER'S TEA PARTY. THAT'S
TAXPAYERS MONEY AS I SEE IT.
AND WE NEED TO RESPECT AND THEY
DESERVE TO HAVE A VOICE. IN
THIS INSTITUTION. THERE'S AN
AREA OF GREAT MAGNITUDE THE
ALSO HAS ALONG THE WAY BEEN
CONSISTENTLY NEGLECT. THAT IS
THE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS. OF
HIGH TECH UPGRADES THAT THE
STATE HAS EMBARKED UPON OVER
THIS MANY YEARS. MANY YEARS
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS GREAT
TENNESSEE IS A PROVIDE
TECHNOLOGY FROM THIS WONDERFUL
STATE. TECHNOLOGICAL CAPITAL OF
THE WORLD. HARDLY. ANY OF THE
WORK. HARDLY ANY BROUGH GOTTEN
DONE ON TIME. HARDLY ANY OF
THEM HAVE EVER COME IN ON
BUDGET. NO THE PROCESS GOES
ALONG. THE CHEESE THE LIMITS OF
TIME. AND THEN THERE'S A TECH
COMPANY THIS IS ALL ALLOW
THERE'S IS NEW BOB DYLAN BANGLA
INDEED THAT'S THE BEST IN THE
WORLD SO WE NEED TO AMEND. THIS
CONTRACT THERE'S BEEN A FEW
MORE BILLION BUT NO PROBLEM
WE'RE GOING TO DO IT. AND THEN
THEY FAIL. NOW SEVERAL YEARS
AGO IT WAS SUGGESTED THAT THERE
WOULD BE A SOLUTION. AG
DEPARTMENT. WAS CREATED. THERE
HAVE BEEN SOME ABLE PEOPLE
HEADING THAT DEPARTMENT EVEN
NOW ARE THERE. HOWEVER THE
PRODUCT. HAS BEEN UTTERLY
LACKING AND GETTING ANYTHING
DONE AND THEY ALL THE IMPORTANT
THING THAT'S BEEN DONE WITH
THESE THIS AGENCY IS IT'S BEEN
RENAMED I THINK NOW THREE TIMES.
THREE TIMES AT LEAST IN MY
COUNTY. IS BEEN RENAMED. DID
THAT CHANGE ANYTHING. I DON'T
THINK TO THIS DAY IT HAS IF
THERE WAS A REFORM THAT SHOULD
HAVE BEEN IN THIS BILL. THAT'S
ONE WE SHOULD GET OUR HANDS ON
AND FIGURE OUT IN THIS
MAGNIFICENT STATE. HOW TO GET
HI TECH APPLICATION THE STATE
AGENCIES RIGHT. AND WE'VE BEEN
NOTHING THAT HAVE BEEN A DISMAL
FAILURE. HERE TO FOR. ONE OTHER
THAT IT WAS OF SOME HISTORIC
INTEREST WITH A TO PORTABLE
TODAY AS WELL. WE DON'T CHANGE
ANYTHING WITHIN THE AGENCY. THE
FORMER GOVERNOR MADE A BIG DEAL
OF BLOWING UP THE BOXES MEETING
THE BUREAUCRACY THESE FAST
AGENCIES THAT CONTROL THE
PEOPLE THAT WE REPRESENT
CONTROLS OUR LIFE. SUCH A HIGH
DEGREE. AND THEY'VE BEEN GIVEN
SUCH A THOMAS. AUTHORITY THE
BIG AGENCIES. WELL. NOT MANY OF
THOSE BOXES GOT BLOWN UP. IN
FACT MY RECALL ONLY ONE DID.
WAS THE BIGGEST ONE. DEPARTMENT
OF CORRECTIONS MANY YEARS AGO.
IRONICALLY AND I ARGUED AT THE
TIME THAT AGENCY. WAS BOTTOM
LIGHT. WORKERS TO THE TOP
FLIGHT AND BOTTOM HEAVY.
MEETING THE ADMINISTRATIVE
OFFICES. WERE FAR TOO. FEW IN
THOSE OFFICES TO RUN AT THAT
TIME A FOUR BILLION DOLLAR
AGENCY NOW I THINK IT'S
SOMETHING A YOU LATER MORE. SO
THE BLOW UP OF THE BOXES TOOK
FOUR WAS. STOP LIGHT AND BOTTOM
HEAVY. AND MADE IT PROPERLY END
BOTTOM HEAVY. THAT'S KIND
REMAIN THAT WAY OVER THE YEARS.
MAYBE STILL NOW AND WE'RE STILL
STRIVING. TO MAKE IT BETTER.
BUT AS I ASK. FOR THIS BILL A
NO VOTE TODAY. I SAY WE DARE
NOT. FOR THE PEOPLE THAT WE
REPRESENT. LITTLE WHAT WILL BE
UP TO A NINE BILLION DOLLAR TAX
INCREASE OUT THERE. IN THE
BUDGET. SO INCREASED AND EVEN A
TOUGH TIME. BETTER NOT. SAY
THAT WE'VE DECLARE VICTORY HERE
TODAY. BECAUSE WE PASSED THE
BUDGET ON TIME. AND HERE WE ARE
AGAIN SOMETHING LIKE WE WERE
AND- JUST A FEW YEARS AGO IN
THE NINETIES. WE SAT DOWN AT
OUR DESKS AND HAD SEVEN HUNDRED
PAGES OF THE BUDGET. COME UP ON
THE COMPUTER BEFORE. AND THEN
VOTED ON THAT LEDGE. WITH NO
CHANCE TO ABSORB IT REVIEW IT
TO TAKE IT. OR EVEN OFFER ANY
CONSTRUCTIVE CHANGES. THAT
ISN'T LATEST GENERAL OF THE
SENATE A BUDGET PROCESS THAT'S
AT BEST A SCRUM. AND I ARGUED
DISSERVICE TO THE CITIZEN WE
REPRESENT. AND THEREFORE I URGE
A NO VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR NELSON SENATOR
MELINDA'S. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND I WANT TO START
OFF BY SAYING THAT I APPRECIATE
THE COMMENTS OF ALL THE
SENATORS HERE AND I ESPECIALLY
APPRECIATE THE- THOUGHTFUL
DELIBERATIONOF THE BUDGET
CHAIR WOMAN THROUGHOUT THIS
WHOLE PROCESS I KNOW THIS IS
NOT AN EASY PROCESS I KNOW THAT
EVERYONE IN HERE'S HEARD. FROM
THEIR CONSTITUENTS WERE VERY
UPSET ABOUT THE CUTS THAT ARE
BEING MADE FROM A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT AREAS WE HAVE ALL
HEARD IT SAID THIS IS NOT EASY
ON ANYONE. BUT I HAVE GREAT
CONCERN WITH THE FACT THAT WE
ARE ADDING. NINE HUNDRED
POSITIONS. TO OUR STATE
GOVERNMENT DURING A TIME WHEN
WE ARE FACING A FIFTY FOUR
BILLION DOLLAR. DEFICIT AND
WE'RE RELYING HEAVILY ON THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO HELP US
PAY THOSE BILLS. ONE HUNDRED
AND THREE POSITIONS TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS FOR THE ENFORCEMENT
AND ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD RELATED
TO AB FIVE. SAID THAT IS
ADDITIONAL PERSONNEL TO GO OUT
IN FORCE AB FIVE WHICH IS
ALREADY HURT A THRIVING ECONOMY
NOW EVEN MORE SO WITH THE
EFFECTS OF KEVIN NINETEEN.
SIXTY THREE POSITIONS FOR
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS FOR ENHANCED LABOR
ENFORCEMENT AND OTHER
ADMINISTRATION- AGAIN GOING OUT
TO PEOPLE WHO ARE TRYING TO
MAKE A LIVING TRYING TO PAY
THEIR TAXES THAT THE STATE HAS
THE REVENUE. IN ORDER TO PAY
FOR ALL THOSE THINGS WE HEARD
ABOUT IN THE LAST TRAILER BILL.
EIGHTY FIVE NEW POSITIONS TO
SHIFT FROM CONTRACTORS TO STATE
EMPLOYEES AT THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL AUTHORITY NOW WHAT'S
INTERESTING TO ME IS IT STATES
THAT THAT THIS IS AN ESTIMATED
EIGHTEEN MILLION DOLLAR
SAVINGS. I DON'T KNOW WHAT KIND
OF MATH IS TO SUGGEST THAT IT'S
AN EIGHTEEN MILLION DOLLAR
SAVINGS WHEN YOU'RE BRINGING ON
TOO MANY THE STATE EMPLOYEES
AND THE COST OF CREDIT ITSELF.
IS HIGHER- THE NEED TO MILLION
DOLLARS IN SAVINGS THAT IS
SUGGESTED WITHIN THIS BUDGET.
THIRTY EIGHT NEW. FOR THE MOTOR
VOTER PROGRAMMING A COST OF SIX
POINT FOUR MILLION FOR THE DMB.
A PROGRAM THE MOTOR VOTER
PROGRAM WHICH WAS GOOD
INTENTIONED. BUT DOESN'T WORK
HAS A NUMBER OF FEELINGS THAT
WE HAVE YET TO ADDRESS. AND
HAVE YET TO COMMIT TO FIXING SO
WHY WOULD WE THEN INVEST MORE
MONEY INTO A PROGRAM. THAT
DOESN'T SEEM TO BE WORKING AND
I WILL ALSO NOTE THAT WE ARE
PUTTING MONEY INTO THE BUDGET.
FOR THE DMB WHICH I THOUGHT. AS
OF EARLIER TODAY WAS GOING TO
BE TO UPDATE THE I. T. OUR
SYSTEM IN THE DMB SAID THAT
THIS MOTOR VOTER PROGRAM COULD
WORK. THE WAY IT WAS INTENDED
WHAT I FOUND OUT WAS THAT IN
FACT THAT IS NOT THE CASE THE
MONEY IS NOT GOING TO INVEST IN
THE I. T. SYSTEM AN UPGRADE.
IT'S JUST GOING TOWARDS
PERSONNEL. SO I DON'T KNOW HOW
THAT IMPROVES THE SYSTEM THAT
WE HAVE PUT INTO PLACE. SO
AGAIN AT A TIME WHERE WE ARE
FACING SUCH A HUGE DEFICIT IN
MAKING SUCH PAINFUL CUTS.
ACROSS THE BOARD THAT HURTS YOU
KNOW IT DOESN'T MATTER WHAT
YOUR- POLITICAL PREFERENCES
WHAT PARTY YOU BELONG TO IT'S
HURTING EVERYONE. I JUST DON'T
UNDERSTAND HOW IN GOOD
CONSCIENCE WE CAN VOTE FOR
THESE TYPES OF INCREASES IN
FUNDING WHEN WE SIMPLY DO NOT
HAVE THE MONEY FOR THOSE
REASONS I WOULD URGE YOU KNOW
ABOUT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CENTER MELINDA'S. SO BRAD.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND I
PERSONALLY WANT TO THANK OUR
BUDGET CHEERING THE COMMITTEE
FOR ALL THEIR HARD WORK AND
GETTING IS TO THIS DAY I KNOW
WAS A TRUNCATED PROCESS BUT
LONG HOURS NONE THE LESS. AND
EXCITED ABOUT A BUDGET THAT I
DO SUPPORT I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SOME COMMENTS I WANT TO FIRST
AGAIN US STATE AND I'M GLAD TO
SEE THAT THE GOVERNOR FOR POLLS
CUTS THE MARTIN LUTHER HOSPITAL
DID NOT MAKE IT INTO THIS
BUDGET AND I WANT TO PERSONALLY
THANK OUR BUDGET CHEER WHO
DESERVES PARTICULAR HERE- AND
MAKING SURE WE SAFEGUARD THIS
VITAL RESOURCE IN THIS
COMMUNITY. THIS HOSPITAL IS ONE
OF ONLY A FEW HOSPITALS THAT
SERVE THE WALKS HARBOR GATEWAY-
COMMUNITIES PRIMARILY
MINORITIES IT'S A HOSPITAL THAT
ROLLS OUT OF THE- ALL RIGHT. SO
NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE. IT'S A
CRITICAL OF FISSILE IN OUR AND
IT SERVES. MANY PEOPLE WHO ARE
LIVE WITHIN THESE HOSPITAL
DESERT'S ANY REDUCTION IN
SERVICES AT MARTIN LUTHER KING
HOSPITAL WOULD WORSEN THEIR
HEALTH. DISPARITIES FOR
MINORITIES IN LOW INCOME.
PATIENTS IN THAT AREA THESE
COULD SHOULD HAVE NEVER BEEN
CONSIDER VERTICALLY DURING A
PANDEMIC THAT HAS HIT PEOPLE OF
COLOR AND COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
THE HARDEST I'M GLAD THE
LEGISLATURE IS AN OUR
BUDGETEERS THIS COMMUNITY. THAT
IS VITALLY NEEDED. MY SECOND
ISSUE OF A DEALING WITH. THE
REAL OF DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS
OVERSIGHT AND I'M GLAD THAT
THIS LEGISLATIVE BODY WILL HAVE
ADDITIONAL TIME TO ADDRESS THAT
ISSUE MANY MEMBERS ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLES AND IN BOTH
HOUSES OF EXPRESS THEIR
CONCERN. AND HAVING OPPORTUNITY
TO DISCUSS THIS- TO VARIOUS
HEARINGS WITHOUT A DOUBT. THIS
IS THE TIME WHEN WE WANT TO
PROTECT CONSUMERS IN YOUR
FINANCES BUT WE ALSO WANT TO
MAKE SURE IT'S DONE IN AN
EFFECTIVE WAY. THAT INCLUDES
IMPROVING HOW WE REORGANIZED.
AT SERVERS. THE DIVERS
CONSUMERS AND BUSINESS OWNERS
YET AGAIN WE HAVE SEEN THIS AND
DURING THIS CRISIS ILLUSTRATED
HOW OFTEN MINORITY COMMUNITIES
AND BUSINESSES ARE OVERLOOKED.
BY PUBLIC PROGRAMS AS WE WELL
KNOW. VERY FEW IF ANY MINORITY
BUSINESSES RECEIVED ANY OF THE
CASHIERS ARE PPP DOLLARS FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN WHAT
LITTLE HAPPEN WAS DURING
SUBSEQUENT WOUND TO DO THE
LEGISLATIVE. BLACK CAUCUS THE
CONGRESSIONAL BLACK CAUCUS AND
FINALLY I APPRECIATE THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE PRO TEM AS
WELL AS OUR- MAJORITY LEADER MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE ECONOMIC
RECOVERY WORKING GROUP AND I
WAS HONORED TO SERVE AS- COACH
HERE THERE WILL BE SOME VITAL
PROPOSALS COMING FORWARD SOON.
IN AREAS OF DEALING WITH. CAN
IT LANDLORD PROTECTION AS WELL
AS BILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO HELP
STIMULATE- BUSINESSES AND I AND
OUR ECONOMY. THESE PROPOSALS
COULD HELP ADDRESS SERIOUS
EQUITY ISSUES AND HOUSING.
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AND SMALL
BUSINESS FUNDING AMONG OTHER
AREAS. THERE WILL ALSO BE.
THEY'RE ALSO COMPANY WILL ALSO
COMPLEMENT I SHOULD SAY THE
BUDGET BY BEING MINDFUL. TO ARE
LIMITED BUDGET RESOURCES. THERE
ARE EXACTLY THESE ARE EXACTLY
THE KIND OF FORT MEANING FAST
MOVING PROPOSALS THAT WE NEED
TO GET THROUGH. THIS CRISIS I
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING THE MOVE
FOR WE'RE FACING MULTIPLE
CHALLENGES AS A STATE AND AS A
NATION BUT THIS BUDGET IS NOT
ONE OF THEM I LOOK FOR TO AND I
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CENTER BRADFORD SENATOR GROVE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I TOO
WOULD LIKE TO THINK- THE BUDGET
CHAIR FOR THE- WORK THAT SHE
PUT INTO THIS BUDGET BILL AND
SPECIFICALLY AS UNITED STATES
MILITARY VETERAN ACTUALLY FIRST
FEMALE VETERAN IT'S EVER SERVED
ON THIS FLOOR. MODERN TO BE
JOINED BY MY COLLEAGUE AND THAT
JUST BECAME AND A SENATOR ON
THIS FLOOR BUT IS A FEMALE THAT
TREND. I AM- VERY GRACIOUS AND
VERY THANKFUL THAT THE BUDGET
CHAIR DID NOT ALLOW FOR THE
VETERANS HOME IN BARSTOW TO
DISPLACE ALMOST TWO HUNDRED
VETERANS THAT HAVE- DEFENDED
THIS NATION AND THEN TO BE
KICKED OUT OF THEIR HOMES-
BECAUSE THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
CRISIS OR THE BUDGET. THAT THE
GOVERNOR SUBMIT A STATE
LEGISLATURE I THINK THE
BUDGETARY. FOR MAKING SURE THAT
THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN I REALLY DO
APPRECIATE IT AND SO TO THE
VETERANS OF THE PART OF THAT TO
SOME THAT. THIS I DO. NOT TO
THE BILL A VERY ELSE THAT IS IN
THE BILL. MANY LOOK AT. WHAT IN
ON AND PIECE ALLEGE. IS A BY.
IT'S NOW TRANSPARENT LIKE MIKE.
FROM TO HIM HAS JUST ADDRESS
THAT IT WAS DONE IN A BACKROOM
DEAL. WERE MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS DID NOT HAVE THE
REPRESENTATION- TO HAVE THEIR
VOICES HEARD. REGARDING THIS
BUDGET DEAL SO I IF I OPPOSE
THIS BILL BECAUSE THE
TRANSPARENCY ISSUE. I ALSO
OPPOSE THIS BILL BECAUSE THE
TWENTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS THAT
IS IN THERE FOR AB FIVE. WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE TWENTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS THAT IS IN
THERE FOR AB FIVE THERE'S
TWENTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS. TO
STOP REPAIR PERSONS LAND
SURVEYORS CAMPAIGN WORKERS
CATERS INTERPRETERS MUSICIANS.
FRANCHISEES IN FRANCHISE
ORDERS. THAT TWENTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS IN THERE TO STOP THEM
FROM PROVIDING FOR THEIR
FAMILIES. STOP THEM FOR BEING
AN INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR IN
OWNING THEIR OWN BUSINESS. IT
STOPS THEM FROM THE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO ENGAGE TO PROVIDE. FOR
THEIR RENT THEIR HOUSING AND
JUST LIKE I SAID PROVIDING FOR
FOOD ON THE TABLE FOR THEIR
FAMILIES. IN THE BEGINNING OF
THIS COVER NINETEEN SITUATION
THE GOVERNOR PUT OUT AN ALL OUT
CALL HE WAS CALLED THE-
CALIFORNIA HEALTH CORPS.
CALLING ALL THESE INDIVIDUALS
BACK TO THE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM
SO THAT WE COULD HAVE A
RELIABLE FRONT LINE HEALTH CARE
WORK FORCE. IN ORDER TO ADDRESS
THE CODE NINETEEN SITUATION. SO
WITH THIS TWENTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS THAT'S PUT IN THIS
BUDGET FOR AB FIVE AFTER THE
GOVERNOR PUT OUT THAT CALL FOR
ALL OF THESE HEALTH CARE
WORKERS TO COME FORWARD. ALL
THAT ARE AFFECTED BY EIGHTY
FIVE IN THIS MONEY THAT'S GOING
TO STOP NURSE PRACTITIONERS.
PHYSICIAN'S ASSISTANTS ARE TOM
A TRYST. PHYSICAL THERAPIST
RESPIRATORY THERAPIST RATE A
RADIATION THERAPIST. ALL THESE
INDIVIDUALS THAT WE CALLED UPON
TO STEP FORWARD AND COME AND
HELP RESCUE US WITH THIS CODE
NINETEEN SITUATION. THIS
PARTICULAR PIECE OF LEGISLATION
WILL FIND POSITIONS TO STOP
THEM FROM BEING EMPLOYED. WHEN
I LOOK AT THE TWENTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS THAT'S OUT
THERE TO STOP INDIVIDUALS FROM
THE GIG ECONOMY DOOR DASH THE
SINGLE MOMS THE RETIREES THAT
USE THIS AS ADDITIONAL INCOME
TO SUPPLEMENT THEIR RETIREMENT
OR TO SUPPLEMENT THEIR- THEIR
HOUSING COST WHEN THEY GO TO
WIN THEIR KIDS GO TO SCHOOL AND
THEY HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK. THIS BILL FUNDS TWENTY
TWO MILLION DOLLARS IN
POSITIONS TO NOT ALLOW THESE
INDIVIDUALS TO WORK. WHEN I
THINK ABOUT THE TWO POINT NINE
MILLION DOLLARS IT'S GOING TO
BE ALLOCATED I'M SORRY TWO
POINT NINE BILLION WITH A B.
NOT AGAIN MY APOLOGIES. TWO
POINT NINE BILLION DOLLARS IN
IN RESOURCES THAT ARE GOING TO
TAX REVENUE FROM PEOPLE THAT
PAY TAXES IN THE STATE. PRIVATE
BUSINESSES TO FIND POSITIONS
FOR THE CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED
RAIL WHICH IS A COMPLETE
DISASTER DESTROYING OUR CENTRAL
VALLEY. BUDGET AND NOW WE'RE
ADDING ANOTHER TWO POINT NINE
BILLION DOLLARS IN POSITIONS
FOR THAT THAT RAIL FAIL. WE
HAVE FIFTY FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
STATE BUDGET DEFICIT WE'VE GOT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN THIS
BUDGET FOR A STATE PARK AND I
KNOW ALL OF US UP HERE YOU GUYSTHINK THAT JUST BUDGET THAT'S
WHERE EVEN ADDRESSING FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS. WHERE IS A
STATE PARK OUT RECENTLY AND CAN
BE PURCHASED FROM FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS WOULD GO A LONG WAYS TO
SOMEBODY WHO. DOES NOT HAV A
JOB AND IS ONE OF THOSE FOUR
POINT EIGHT MILLION PEOPLE OUT
OF WORK THAT ARE WATCHING THIS
HEARING AND KNOWING THAT. THE
THINGS THAT WERE ADDRESSING IN
THIS BUDGET DON'T EVEN
ADDRESSED THE SITUATION THAT WE
HAVE WITH FOUR POINT EIGHT
MILLION UNEMPLOYED CALIFORNIANS
IN BUSINESSES THAT ARE
STRUGGLING TO SURVIVE. YEAH SIX
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS. FOR
BEST SIERRA. FOR THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO SUE THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION. WE'VE SATISFIED
IN THIS BUDGET SIX POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS. SIX POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS. TO PAY FOR
LAWSUIT SO THAT THIS. DATA
CALIFORNIA CAN SUE THE PRESS
THE STRIP ADMINISTRATION THE
PRESENT UNITED STATES. BUT YET
WERE ALSO ON THE OTHER SIDE.
BAD HE KNEW HIM. WERE BEGGING
HIM FOR FOURTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS IN BAILOUT SO THAT THIS
BODY CAN MEET THE NEEDS THAT IT
HAS. DETECTED SPENDING IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. SO WE'RE
EITHER LIKE A GOVERNOR SAYS A
NATION STATE. AND WE'RE
APPLYING FOR FOREIGN AID FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OR WE
ARE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
WE'RE GOING TO WORK HAND IN
HAND WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IN ORDER TO RECEIVE
THOSE FUNDS. AND SET ASIDE SIX
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO
SEE THE PRESIDENT. IT'S JUST
CRAZY. ALL THE INFORMATION THAT
LEADS UP TO THIS BUDGET. THERE
ARE SO MANY THINGS IN THERE IN
THIS BUDGET THAT ARE NOT
TRANSPARENT. THAT MAKE NO SENSE
THE DON'T PRIDE IN PROVIDING
QUALITY AND THAT HINDER IN HURT
OUR PRIVATE BUSINESS SECTOR SO
THAT WE CAN'T PROVIDE JOBS. TO
RAISE THE OR TO IT TO PAY TAXES
AND PAY EMPLOYEES. AND HAVE
THEM PAY INTO THE STATE WHICH
PAYS FOR EVERYTHING THAT WE
SPEND HERE. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A NO VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR GROPE SENATOR CABALLERO.
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT. THURSDAY
PRESIDENT FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TODAY- I WANT TO START
OFF BY THINKING OUR BUDGET
CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR CREATING THE FRAMEWORK IN
THE GUIDE TO HELP OUR THINKING
IN THIS I THINK THE WORK THAT%
WAS DONE WAS REALLY INCREDIBLE
AND FRANKLY WE'VE BEEN LOOKING
AT THE SAME LANGUAGE IN THE
SAME MATURE AS A BUDGET
COMMITTEE FOR A PERIOD OF TIME
AND I WANT TO START OFF BY
SAYING I AM. IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL- WE ABSOLUTELY
NEED TO PASS THIS BILL. BUT
THERE IS I RISE TODAY TO VOICE
MY CONCERNS ABOUT PLACE HOLDER
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL THAT
APPROPRIATES FUNDS TO THE STATE
AIR RESOURCES BOARD TO CONDUCT
RULE MAKING. TO CONSIDER
CHANGES TO THE CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM SO WE'RE GOING TO SEE
THAT IT SOME OTHER TIME. BUT
BECAUSE IT HAD THERE'S
PLACEHOLDER LANGUAGE IN THIS
BILL. I WANTED TO OPEN IT ABOUT
IT. IT CREATES A MANDATE TO
CONDUCT A RULE MAKING THAT THE
AIR RESOURCES BOARD SAYS IT
DOES NOT NEED. THREE YEARS AGO
AB THREE NINETY EIGHT WHICH
FORMALLY ENACTED THE CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM IS STATUTORILY.
WITH BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. AND
SIGNIFICANT NEGOTIATIONS AND
COMPROMISES BY EVERYONE- YOU'LL
REMEMBER THAT IT WAS A
DIFFICULT NEGOTIATION. AND IN
pTHE END. WE PASSED A BILL THAT
REQUIRED THE A. R. B. USING ITS
BEST AVAILABLE SCIENCE TO
UNDERTAKE A RULE MAKING AND
AFTER MORE THAN A YEAR A PUBLIC
WORKSHOPS AND HEARINGS. THEIR
FINAL REGULATIONS WERE ADOPTED.
AND ALTHOUGH THE IMMEDIATE
PROGRAM CHANGES TOOK EFFECT IN
APRIL OF TWENTY NINETEEN. THAT
MAJOR CHANGES WON'T GO INTO
EFFECT UNTIL NEXT YEAR. AND SO
THE PROPONENTS OF THIS NEW RULE
MAKING BY THE ERROR BE THEY
RELY ON A REPORT THAT WAS
PREPARED BY THE LA- AND THE LA-
ISSUED THE REPORT IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WHICH WAS
PRIOR TO THE A. R. B. STARTING.
THEIR RULE MAKING PROCESS. AND
IN THAT REPORT THE LA-
ACKNOWLEDGED THAT THE REVENUES
WOULD FLUCTUATE BASED ON
EMISSIONS. PER YEAR THERE ARE
BE CONSIDERED THE ISSUE AS PART
OF THEIR TO TWENTY EIGHTEEN
RULE MAKING AND AS UPDATING
DATED THERE SCOPING PLAN SINCE
THEN SO THEY'VE TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION ABOUT THE LA
CONCERNS EQUALLY OF CONCERN IS
THAT. THE LANGUAGE THAT WE'VE
BEEN LOOKING AT AND THAT
LANGUAGE COULD CHANGE THE
LANGUAGE WE'VE BEEN LOOKING AT.
WOULD REQUIRE. THAT NEW RULE
MAKING OCCUR WITHOUT THE
BENEFIT OF THE ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCEDURES ACT THAT ACT ARE THE
LEGISLATURE'S. PROCEDURES THAT
WE PUT IN PLACE TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC IN ENSURE A DEMOCRATIC
PROCESS SO TO SET UP A RULE
MAKING IT SAY BUT YOU DON'T
NEED TO. TO DO THE DEAL WITH
THE APA ON THIS IS JUST
OUTRAGEOUS AND SO WHAT IT WOULD
DO IS UNDER MY IT WOULD OPEN
THE WHOLE PROCESS TO LEGAL
CHALLENGE AND UNDERMINE THE
MARKET CONFIDENCE. HOLDING A
PUBLIC MEANING IS NOT MEANING
IN A MEANINGFUL EQUIVALENT TO A
PUBLIC NOTICE. AND PUBLICATION
REQUIREMENTS IN THE PUBLIC
REGISTER SO THIS PROPOSAL
SIGNIFICANT SIGNIFICANTLY STEPS
ALL OVER AND VIOLATE AGREEMENTS
THAT WERE MADE A SCANT THREE
YEARS AGO. AND I WANT TO
REPEAT. I SUPPORT. SB SEVENTY
FOUR. AND I HOPE THAT WE CAN
ELIMINATE THE ANTICIPATED
FUNDING THAT'S NOT NEEDED BY A
RB- AND THAT REQUIRES
UNNECESSARY RULE MAKING THAT
GIVES THEM MORE POWER TO MAKE
COME
OUR APPROVAL SO- I AND I DO
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND LOOK
FORWARD TO HOPEFULLY SEE THAT.
BILL DISAPPEAR. THANK HE SAID
CABALLERO CENTER MORAL. THANK
YOU MADAM. COLLEAGUES AT THE
RECESSION GOVERNOR GOVERNOR
BROWN WORRIED ABOUT FEARED WHAT
TIME IS HERE. AND IT CAME ON
LIKE A HEART ATTACK JUST IN A
MATTER OF A FEW MONTHS.
REGRETFULLY RECESSIONS HAVE A
HISTORY OF STAYING FOR A FEW
YEARS AND THIS IS MY MAJOR
CONCERN ABOUT THE BUDGET. FOR
THIS YEAR AND MOVING. AS WE
DISCUSS SB EIGHT OH EIGHT AND
SB SEVENTY FOUR. CONSEQUENTLY
RELYING ON OUR ON OUR RAINY DAY
FUND PROBABLY WON'T MAKE IT THE
DISTANCE. HOPING ON FEDERAL
FUNDS IT'S A UNIQUE STRATEGY
FOR A STATE NOT CONSIDERED
PHYSICALLY WELL MANAGED BY MOST
OF THE OTHER STATES. AFTER ALL
WE HAVE ONE OF THE LARGEST
UNRESTRICTED NET DEFICIT THAT
DEFICITS IN THE NATION WE ARE
RACING NEW JERSEY AND ILLINOIS
TO THE BOTTOM. AND IN HELLA
BURSTING IS THAT. CALIFORNIA'S
PER CAPITA NUMBERS PUT IT IN
THE BOTTOM TEN STATES. IN OUR
STATE CONTROLLER IS THE ONLY
ONE OUT OF FIFTY STATES IN THIS
NATION THAT HASN'T PRODUCED
AUDITED FINANCIAL STATEMENTS.
OUR CONSTITUENTS ARE REELING. I
USED TO BE CHAIRMAN OF A CREDIT
COUNSELING NONPROFIT AND BOY
YOU KNOW HOW CLOSE PEOPLE ARE
JUST A TEETERING ONE PAYCHECK
AWAY IT CENTERED CENTER THIS IS
A TOUGH TIME. BECAUSE I BELIEVE
THIS COVERT NINETEEN RECESSION
WILL BE A MULTI YEAR EVENT.
THIS BUDGET AND THIS BODY ARE
IGNORING THREE CRITICAL
STRATEGIES. THE FIRST IS
DOWNSIZING REDUCING STAFFING IS
WHAT OUR COUNTERPARTS AT THE
COUNTIES CITIES AND SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE DOING AS WE SPEAK.
WE CAN'T KEEP LYING AT OR NEAR
THE TWO HUNDRED TWENTY TWO
BILLION DOLLAR LEVEL. AND
MAINTAINING CURRENT SPENDING
LEVELS SHOULD BE REEVALUATED.
THE LONGER SACRAMENTO WAITS TO
MAKE REAL CUTS VERSUS
CAPRICIOUS TRIGGER CUTS. THE
GREATER THE PAIN WILL BE IN THE
NEXT TWO FISCAL YEARS. YOU'VE
ALREADY HEARD ONE SIMPLE
RECOMMENDATION DROP HIGH SPEED
RAIL LET'S GET REAL. THAT WOULD
REALLY MESSAGE TO THE
CONSTITUENTS THAT SACRAMENTO
SERIOUS ABOUT IT. BALANCING ITS
BUDGETS. TO TWO YEARS YOU'LL BE
NOTIFIED BY CALPERS AND CAL
STIRS AT THE DEFINED BENEFIT
PENSION PLAN ANNUAL REQUIRED
CONTRIBUTIONS WILL RISE AND
PROBABLY SIGNIFICANTLY. SCHOOL
DISTRICTS COULD BARELY MAKE
THEIR PAYMENTS THE LAST FEW
YEARS EVEN WITH PROP NINETY
EIGHT FUNDING INCREASES.
BECAUSE OF THEIR REQUIREMENT TO
ADD MORE TO THEIR PENSION PLAN
CONTRIBUTIONS. WHAT REALLY
NEEDS TO OCCUR CALLING SAYS IS
AND THE SOONER THE BETTER IS A
MASSIVE PENSION REFORM. THE
GOVERNOR WOULD BE WISE TO
ESTABLISH A COMMITTEE TO MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS. THE STATE OF
WISCONSIN AMPLE STATE OF
WISCONSIN IMPLEMENTED A SHARED
RISK PLAN IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
TWO. AND IT HAS HISTORICALLY
BEEN FULLY FUNDED FOR MANY
YEARS NOW. AND IT IT'S CONCEPT
THAT WE SHOULD LOOK AT BUT
STUBBORNLY HANGING ON TO THE
CURRENT PLANS MEANS NO PAY
RAISES OR COST OF LIVING
INCREASES. THE STATE EMPLOYEES
FOR SEVERAL YEARS THEY CAN HAVE
BOTH A DEFINED BENEFIT PENSION
PLAN AND PAY RAISES THE MATH
JUST WILL NOT WORK. IT'S UP TO
THEM TALK TO US WITH YOUNGER
EMPLOYEES PREFER. TO BE ABLE TO
MAKE MORTGAGE PAYMENTS AND PAY
FOR CHILD CARE OR THEY WANT TO
HAVE MORE WITHHELD FROM THEIR
PAYCHECKS SO THEY CAN FIND A
PENSION PLAN WHICH EVENTUALLY
MAY NOT BE SUSTAINABLE. THREE
ANOTHER SYSTEMIC BUDGET BUSTER
THAT CAN AND SHOULD E TAMED.
IS RETIREE MEDICAL. BUT
UNFUNDED LIABILITY OF SOME
NINETY BILLION DOLLARS IS A
HUNGRY ANIMAL TO FEED IN.
ORANGE COUNTY ADDRESS THEIR
UNFUNDED ACTUAL REAL CRUDE
LIABILITY IN TWO THOUSAND SIX
WE WERE ABLE TO WORK WITH THE
BARGAINING UNITS AND WE REDUCED
OUR UNFUNDED LIABILITY BY 71%
IF WE COULD DO THAT FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THROUGH
THIS BODY WE COULD REMOVE SIXTY
BILLION FROM OUR BALANCE SHEET
WE COULD REMOVE A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF ANUAL REQUIRED
CONTRIBUTIONS AND YOU MAY FIND
THE RESOURCES THAT YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR. FROM DC. CALLING
FOR ALL TERM LIMITED. BUT WE
STILL NEED TO TAKE A LONG TERM
PERSPECTIVE. AND A CRISIS
PROVIDES OPPORTUNITIESIT'S
JUST A MATTER OF LEADERSHIP.
THE DAYS OF TAX INCREASES ARE
OVER THE DAYS OF PUTTING BONDS
ON THE BALLOT SHOULD ALSO BE
OVER THE DAYS OF GOLD PLATED
PENSIONS MUST COME TO AN END
AND BETTER RETIREMENT
STRATEGIES MUST BE PURSUED MOVE
FORWARD. THE RETIREE MEDICAL
PLANS THAT DON'T EVEN INTEGRATE
WITH MEDICARE ARE INEXCUSABLE.
COLLEAGUES I'VE BEEN THROUGH A
MUNICIPAL BANKRUPTCY CHAPTER
NINE I'VE BEEN THROUGH THE
GREAT RECESSION CHAIRMAN OF THE
BOARD OF ORANGE COUNTY IN TWO
THOUSAND AND TWELVE. DIFFICULT
TIMES BUT THE SOONER YOU MOVE
THE BETTER GOES AND- THIS THE
SELF INDUCED ECONOMIC PANIC OR-
WHAT WE'RE IN DURING NOW HAS TO
BE ADDRESSED FOR THE LONG TERM
GIVING IT A COUPLE OF ASPIRINS
AND HOPING SACRAMENTO AND ITS
SUBSIDIARIES WILL BE FINE IN
THE MORNING. WILL NOT CUT IT.
CONSEQUENTLY I WILL BE OPPOSED
TO THIS BUDGET THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU SENATOR
MORLOCKS SENATOR JONES. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS- MENOPAUSE I'M GONNA
TRY TO. RESTRAIN MY EMOTION.
AND ANGER AS I SHARE MY
COMMENTS THIS MORE THIS
AFTERNOON. BUT I WANT TO SHARE
THAT THE THAT THIS BUDGET IS
PERSONALLY OFFENSIVE. TO ME.
AND WHILE IT OPPRESSES TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE IN MY
DISTRICT. IT ALSO PRESSES.
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA. WE HEAR OFTEN THAT
THE BUDGET REVEALS OUR VALUES.
AND THIS BUDGET DRAWS A BRIGHT
LINE. BETWEEN THE VALUES OF THE
MINORITY PARTY AND THE VALUES
OF THE MAJORITY PARTY BUT NOT
ONLY THAT BUT A BRIGHT LINE
BETWEEN THE VALUES OF THE
MAJORITY PARTY. AND THE VALUES
OF CALIFORNIANS AS A WHOLE.
WELL MOST OF THE MEMBERS OF THE
MAJORITY OF THE MINORITY PARTY.
HAVE OWNED BUSINESSES. BEN
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS. HIRED
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS. AND
RELIED ON THEM. FOR TO GET WORK
DONE. A HAND FULL IN THE
MAJORITY PARTY THAT HAD THAT
SAME EXPERIENCE. WELL MANY
CALIFORNIANS WAKE UP EVERY
MONDAY MORNING TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW THEY'RE GOING TO MAKE
PAYROLL BY FRIDAY. AND PAY THE
WITHHOLDING TAXES FOR THEIR
EMPLOYEES BY FRIDAY. OR BUILD
THEIR BUSINESS OR EXPAND THEIR
BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA. VIEW
THE MAJORITY PARTY OF HAD THAT
EXPERIENCE OR RESPONSIBILITY.
WHILE MANY IN THE MINORITY
PARTY IN CALIFORNIA OF HAVE THE
STRESS. OF HIRING GOOD
EMPLOYEES. AND REALLY SEEING
OUR FIRING BAD EMPLOYEES. ZERO
IN THE MAJORITY PARTY I'VE HAD
THAT STRESS OR EXPERIENCE. WHY
DOES THIS LEGISLATURE CONTINUE
TO PRESS HARD WORKING HONEST
CALIFORNIANS I JUST WANT TO
MAKE A LIVING IN CALIFORNIA. TO
PAY FOR THE COLLEGE FOR THEIR
CHILDREN TO PAY THEIR TAXES TO
BUY A HOME TO BUILD A HOME.
TWENTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS. AS
THE MINORITY LEADER HAS ALREADY
MENTIONED TO ENFORCE. EIGHTY
FIVE. ALL OF YOU ALL OF US HAVE
HEARD OVERWHELMINGLY OVER AND
OVER SINCE JANUARY. FROM
CONSTITUENTS IN OUR DISTRICTS.
THAT ARE STRUGGLING UNDER THE
OPPRESSIVE NATURE OF AB FIVE.
JUST ON THURSDAY I HAD ASSUME
CALL WITH SEVERAL- TATTOO
ARTISTS NOT JUST FOR MY
DISTRICT WERE FROM ALL OVER SAN
DIEGO COUNTY. NOW I DON'T HAVE
ANY TATTOOS. NOBODY IN MY
FAMILY HAS ANY TATTOOS. BUT
BEING ATTACHED TO TALK ARTIST
IS A LEGITIMATE BUSINESS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WHY ARE WE
PREVENTING THEM WHY ARE YOU
PREVENTNG THEM FROM DOING
THEIR WORK AND PROVIDING FOR
THEIR FAMILY. NOW WHY IS HIS
BUDGET PERSONALLY OFFENSIVE TO
ME. AS FOR MOST OF MY LIFE I'VE
BEEN AN INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR.
MY WIFE IS CURRENTLY AN
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR. AND
NOW. WE'RE GONNA SPEND TWENTY
TWO MILLION DOLLARS. FOR
RELEASE. THE STATE AGENCIES.
ENFORCEMENT AGENTS WHOEVER THEY
MIGHT BE. ARE A HARD WORKING
SMALL BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA.
AND AS I LOOK AROUND ON THIS
FLOOR TODAY I KNOW THAT I HAVE
SEVERAL COLLEAGUES A HANDFUL OF
COLLEAGUES. IN THE MAJORITY
PARTY THAT OF OWN SMALL
BUSINESSES HAVE BEEN
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS. AND
MAYBE STILL HIGHER INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS AS YOU VOTE I ON
THIS BILL TODAY AS YOU VOTE I
ON THIS BUDGET TODAY. AND YOU
GIVE THE GOVERNOR MORE
AUTHORITY TO SHUT DOWN THOSE
SMALL BUSINESSES. I WANT YOU TO
ASK YOURSELF. WHY DO YOU
CONTINUE TO ALLOW THIS
GOVERNMENT TO A PRESS SMALL
BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA. WHEN
IS IT GONNA STOP. WHEN ARE WE
GONNA ALLOW CALIFORNIANS TO
MAKE AN HONEST LIVING AND KEEP
THEIR BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA.
THE ONLY THING THAT I CAN HOPE
FOR. IS THAT THE VOTERS. IN
CALIFORNIA WILL REMEMBER THIS
DAY. WHEN THE DEMOCRATS WON'T
REPRESENTS SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS THE REPUBLICANS WILL AND
I HOPE THAT IS REMEMBERED ON
NOVEMBER THIRD THIS YEAR. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I ASK FOR A
NO VOTE ON SB SEVENTY FOUR
THANK YOU SENATOR JONES SENATOR
BILL. BETTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS.
THIS WILL BE THE LAST TIME THAT
I ADDRESS THE LEGISLATURE ON
THE BUDGET. PROBABLY AS A
LEGISLATOR ALTHOUGH PROBABLY
COME TO THE BUDGET HEARINGS AND
TESTIFY- IN THE FUTURE. AND I
WANT TO GO ON RECORD SAYING FOR
THE TATTOO REMOVAL PROGRAM IN
THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
OKAY. JUST SO WE TALK ABOUT
TATTOOS HERE. THIS IS GOING TO
BE A HARD VOTE. JUST LIKE WITH.
IN THE PAST. I WANT TO REMAKE
MAKE SOME REMARKS ON SOME
ISSUES- THAT IMPACT- MY
DISTRICT AND CALIFORNIANS THAT-
ARE VULNERABLE TO THIS BUDGET.
FIRST OF ALL. I WAS EXCITED THE
BEGINNING OF THE YEAR TO DO
SOME FOSTER CARE REFORM. AND I
WASN'T ABLE TO DO THAT DO THIS-
BUDGET BUT I WANTED TO STATE
THIS. EVEN IN THE LIMITATIONS
WE FACE. SIMILAR TO THE
LIMITATIONS WHEN THE
SIGNIFICANT FOSTER CARE
LEGISLATION THAT WE ADOPTED IN
TWENTY ELEVEN WHEN WE HAD A
FORTY BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET
DEFICIT THAT AB TWELVE WAS
ADOPTED IN SIGNED INTO LAW BY
GOVERNOR SCHWARZENEGGER WE CAN
DO A LOT. TO HELP FOSTER USE.
AND PRESERVE THEY'RE HOPEFUL
KNOWS THAT THEY HAVE IN OUR
LIVES THERE'S THINGS YOU CAN DO
EVEN THOUGH YOU HAVE AND HAS
BEEN DONE BEFORE WITH A. B.
TWELVE. WHICH IS REALLY HELP
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF FOSTER USE
OF IN OUR IN OUR STATE. AND I'M
WORKING. HAND IN HAND WITH
ABBOTT. TO PROVIDE PROTECTIONS
FOR FOSTER USE IN TERMS OF THIS
EMERGENCY DO YOU KNOW THAT THE
PROTECTION OF FOR. RELIEVING
FOSTER YOU FROM THE FOSTER YOU
SYSTEM EXPIRES. ON JUNE
THIRTIETH. THE UNLESS WE EXTEND
THE CARE. FOR FOSTER USE THE
THAT WILL EXPIRE. AND THAT
PEOPLE WILL NOT RECEIVE ANY
BENEFITS FROM THE FOSTER USE
SYSTEM. AND I THINK IN TERMS OF
EMERGENCIES. THE GOVERNOR AND
THE LEGISLATURE IN THE FUTURE
SHOULD ADDRESS THAT. NOW. I
WANT TO SAY THAT I'VE BEEN TO.
IN MY FOURTEEN YEARS HERE. OUT
TWENTY FIVE CALIFORNIA PENAL
INSTITUTIONS AND WHEN I GO I
ALWAYS ASKED THE WARDEN SO I
SAID WELL CAN YOU TELL ME- IF
YOU HAVE ANY KNOWLEDGE OF. HOW
MANY FOSTER YOUTH YOU HAVE. IN
THE- FORMER FROSTY IF YOU HAVE
IN YOUR FACILITY. AND I HEAR
3540% IS A COMMON ANSWER
SOMETIMES 25% IN THE WOMEN'S
PRISON IS HIGHER. THESE ARE
BILLS CHILDREN. THEY'VE HAD
LIVES WITH HIS CHILDREN. THAT
WE WERE RESPONSIBLE FOR. YEAH A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF AMANDA
PATRICIAN. SO IT SEEMS TO ME
THERE ARE IN ORDER TO DO A GOOD
JOB. IF YOU WANT TO LOOK AT IT.
FROM A JUST A FISCAL STANDPOINT
YOU REALLY YOU KNOW. THE COST
OF TAKING CARE OF THE FOSTER
USE IN A PRISON AT NINETY ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR
AVERAGE. CALIFORNIA COST. SEEMS
TO ME THAT. WE OUGHT TO LOOK AT
EXTENDING THE SERVICES FOR
FOSTER YOU BEYOND AGE TWENTY
ONE. AND I HOPE THE GOVERNOR
NEWSOME. GIVES GOOD ATTENTION
TO THIS ISSUE. IT'S A FISCALLY
AND MORALLY RESPONSIBLE THING
TO DO. NOW SECOD LAKE I
ADDRESS LAST WEEK IN THE BUDGET.
COMMITTEE ANOTHER AREA THAT I
THINK WE NEED TO LOOK AT THAT
IS NOT BEEN LOOKED OUT FOR
AWHILE IN A VERY COMPREHENSIVE
WAY AND THAT'S THE ISSUE OF THE
COUNTY STATE. YOU KNOW WE SPEND
TWELVE BILLION DOLLARS. ON
REALIGNMENT THE TWO REALIGNMENT
THE NINETY ONE THE TWENTY
ELEVEN REALIGNMENT PROGRAMS
THAT'S UP TO. TWELVE BILLION
DOLLARS. DO WE THINK THAT THE
MAKE UP OF THE REALIGNMENT
PERCENTAGE IS CORRECT. IS
SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD REVIEW.
I THINK IN LIGHT OF. ALL THE
RECENT EVENTS IN OUR COMMUNITY.
ASKING US TO END RACISM TO LOOK
AT SOCIAL JUSTICE TO LOOK AT
POLICE EXPENDITURES TO LOOK AT
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEMS IN A
DIFFERENT WAY I THINK IT'S OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO LOOK AT THE
FUNDING OF THOSE PROGRAMS THAT
WE PROVIDE TO COUNTY SINCE TWO
COUNTIES IN TERMS OF
REALIGNMENT AND I THINK IT'S
OUR RESPONSIBILITY. THAT WE-
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA THAT
WE'RE GOING TO LOOK AT THOSE
ISSUES. SO I THINK I WOULD URGE
THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE. TO CONTINUE TO
EXAMINE THE ISSUE OF
REALIGNMENT. DIRECT EXAMINE
WHETHER OR NOT THE PRIORITIES
ARE THE PROGRAMS WE WANT THE
GOVERNMENT LOOKED AT IN LEAST
TEN YEARS. DO WE WANT TO CHANGE
THE PRIORITIES TO MORE.
PROGRAMS ACTUALLY ARE BASED ON
PERFORMANCE IN WORK AND THAT
ACTUALLY PRODUCE RESULTS. THAT
WE WANT FOR PUBLIC SAFETY. AND
BETTER CONDITIONS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. AND LASTLY I WANT
TO ASK THAT THE CONTINUE
DISCUSSION. REGARDING SANTA
CLARA COUNTY SAN FRANCISCO IRAN
NAPA. AND SAN MATTEO COUNTIES
CONTINUE IN TERMS OF THE
FORMULA FOR E. ROUGH I THINK
THAT. HOPEFULLY A COMPROMISE
SOLUTION CAN BE WORKED OUT. I
THINK IF. THE COST OF THESE
PROGRAMS ON COUNTIES IN TERMS
OF THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SYSTEM
IS ONEROUS. AND IF IS INDEED
THE DECISION. TWO IMPOSED. HE'S
I THINK IT'S ONLY FAIR THAT
SOME KIND OF ACCOMMODATION IN
TERMS OF THE PAYMENT BE MADE.
IN LIGHT OF THE FACT THAT MOST
THESE COUNTIES ARE SUFFERING.
IN THOSE VERY PROGRAMS WE CARE
ABOUT. HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN TERMS OF BUDGET
DEFICITS. SO I THINK THOSE ARE
ISSUES I WANTED REYES I THANK
YOU AND I PLOD. THE WORK O ALL
THE- PEOPLE WORKING ON THE
BUDGET EXPRESS ESPECIALLY- OF.
THE CHAIR WHO'S WORK VERY HARD
AND ROUGH TIME. THIS YEAR. A
LOT OF PROGRAMS. THE CHAIR
WANTED. WE'RE ACTUALLY CUT. I
KNOW HOW HARD IT WAS. AND I
APPRECIATE THE SENATE'S-
INDULGENCE IN MY REMARKS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. BEING PRESENT
THANK YOU SENATOR BILL BEFORE
WE GET ON TO OUR NEXT SPEAKER
IS I JUST WANT TO THANK ALL OF
YOU WHO HAVE KEPT YOUR MOUSE ON
THE ENTIRE TIME A FEW FOLKS
HAVE TAKEN THERE'S OFFICE WILL
REMIND EVERYBODY BUT THAT THE
SENATE DOES REQUIRE US ON THE
FLOOR TO HAVE OUR HOUSE ON.
NEXT IS SENATOR MY. THANK YOU
MADAM. MEMBER THIS TOO IS THE
LAST BUDGET I WILL VOTE ON TIME
COMPLETING TWELVE YEARS IN THE
LEGISLATURE I CAME INTO THE
STATE ASSEMBLY WHEN WE FACED A
FORTY TWO BILLION DOLLAR
DEFICIT. NOW THAT DEFICIT. IN
THAT RECESSION WERE DIRECTLY
TRACEABLE TO THE MALFEASANCE AT
THE FINANCIAL INDUSTRY. A POINT
OF FINANCIAL INDUSTRY THEY
DIDN'T FACE IN NO PROSECUTION
OR ANY JAIL TIME THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS LOST THEIR HOMES.
IN THEIR JOBS AND WE BUILT BACK.
FROM THAT HUMAN COST DEFICIT.
TO BUILDING A ROBUST ECONOMY.
TO REDUCING OUR UNEMPLOYMENT
pLEVELS TO RECORD LEVELS TO
BUILDING OUR RESERVES TO RECORD
LEVELS. THROUGH THE PRUDENT
MANAGEMENT OF OUR BUDGET. IN
THE LAST BUDGET CYCLES. TEN NOW
FACING A FIFTY FOUR BILLION
DOLLAR. SHORTFALL. THE BECAUSE
A PANDEMIC. THE PANDEMIC THEY
JUST KILLED A HUNDRED THOUSAND
AMERICANS IN OVER FIVE THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS IN A PANDEMIC
FRIENDS THAT THERE'S NO END IN
SIGHT. WE DON'T KNOW THE
TRAJECTORY WE CAN'T CONTROL.
WHAT WE CAN DO IS TRY TO
RESPOND RELYING ON SCIENCE AND
BEST PRACTICES AND PART OF THAT
IS MANAGING A BUDGET. IN A
CRISIS THAT WAS NOT ARE MAKING.
BUT WHICH WERE TASKED WITH
NAVIGATING OUR WAY FORWARD. I
ALSO WANT TO COMMEND MADAM
BUDGET CHAIR THE BUDGET STAFF
THE BUDGET COMMITTEE CHAIRS AND
EVERYONE IS SERVED ON OUR
BUDGET COMMITTEES BIPARTISAN
BUDGET COMMITTEES. THAT HAVE
DISCUSS THESE ISSUES AS WE MOVE
FORWARD. THERE'S NO EASY WAY.
TO BRIDGE A FIFTY FOUR BILLION
DOLLAR SHORTFALL. BUT I CREDIT
OUR LEGISLATURE IN THE LEADERS
ARE PRO TEM IN OUR SPEAKER. FOR
MANAGING A BUDGET PROPOSAL
BEFORE US TODAY IN SB SEVENTY
FOUR. THAT TAKES SOME OF THE
GOVERNOR'S ASSUMPTIONS. AND
SOME OF HIS ARCHITECTURE. BUT
WORKS TO MINIMIZE THE ADVERSE
IMPACTS PACKS TO THE MOST
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS. THE
MOST VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS
FOR WHOM WE WANT TO PROTECT
ACCESS TO BASIC HEALTH CARE
BASIC HOUSING. BASIC IN HOME
SUPPORT SERVICES. WHEN WE TAKE
THE OATH OF OFFICE CLOSER OUR
CONSTITUENTS WHO ABSOLUTELY
DEPEND UPON OUR VOICE TO LOOK
OUT FOR THEM. AND LET ME
COMMENT ON OUR SMALL BUSINESS
COMMUNITY. I WAS ACKNOWLEDGED
AS A CHAMPION OF OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES JUST LAST YEAR. BY
STATE WIDE SMALL BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION I RECOGNIZE THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF OUR SMALL
BUSINESS COMMUNITY TO THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA BUT OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE DEPENDENT UPON
THE CONSUMERS WHO SPEND THEIR
MONEY ON THEIR SERVICES OR
THEIR PRODUCTS. IN THIS BUDGET.
IN OUR ABILITY TO MOBILIZE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE BENEFITS.
IN SIXTEEN CERTAIN LIVING
BENEFITS FOR PEOPLE ON CAL
WORKS AND OTHERS YOU KNOW WHERE
THOSE DOLLARS AND UP. THE END
UP BEING SPENT AT THE SMALL
BUSINESSES WHO DEPEND ON THAT
REVENUE TO SUPPORT THEIR
FAMILIES AND THEIR EMPLOYEES.
AGAIN WE DON'T KNOW THE
TRAJECTORY FRIENDS OF COVERT
NINETEEN. BUSINESSES ARE TRYING
TO RE OPEN. RACING TO QUICKLY.
IN A MANNER THAT'S GONNA SET US
FURTHER BACK FOR A LONGER TIME.
THIS BUDGET ALSO. RECOGNIZES
THE CONTRIBUTIONS OF
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS IN THIS
STATE. AND I REPRESENT MANY IN
ONE OF MY COUNTIES. THE
MAJORITY LANGUAGE NATIVE
LANGUAGE IS SPANISH. ONE OF MY
COUNTIES HAS THE HIGHEST
PERCENTAGE OF UNDOCUMENTED
WORKERS THEY ARE ESSENTIAL
WORKERS HARVESTING OUR FOOD ND
CONTINUING TO KEEP OUR FOOD
SUPPLY LINES INTACT. AND YOU
KNOW WHAT EVERY PAYCHECK THOSE
WORKERS RECEIVE. THERE'S
FEDERAL TAX WITHHELD THEIR
SOCIAL SECURITY TAX WITHHELD
THEIR STATE TAX WITHHELD AND
THERE'S LOCAL TAXES WITHHELD.
BUT IT'S TAXATION WITHOUT
REPRESENTATION BECAUSE THOSE
WORKERS PAYING INTO SUSTAIN OUR
SOCIAL SECURITY SYSTEM
FEDERALLY AND TO PAN TO OUR
STATE TAX SYSTEM. TAXATION
WITHOUT REPRESENTATION SO IT
HURTS ME IN PAINS ME TO HEAR
PEOPLE COMPLAIN. WHEN WE HAVE A
BUDGET THAT RECOGNIZES THOSE
CONTRIBUTIONS AND SEEKS TO GIVE
A SMALL PERCENTAGE OF WHAT'S
PAID IN BACK IN THE FORM OF AN
EXPANDED EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT. THAT PROPOSES IN
ANOTHER YEAR. TO PROVIDE MEDI
CAL SUPPORT FOR SENIORS MOST OF
WHOM FINISHED THEIR WORK OF
HARD LABOR AT MINIMUM WAGE
WITHOUT A PENSION. WITHOUT
ELIGIBILITY FOR SOCIAL SECURITY.
AND WHO WE ARE TRYING IN THIS
BUDGET. TO FOR CASTS TO
SUPPORT. ACCESS TO BASIC
MEDICAL CARE. NOT EMERGENCY
ROOM SERVICES AT THE END OF THE
ROAD. PREVENTIVE CARE. HUMAN
DIGNITY ACCESS TO BASIC HUMAN
HEALTH SERVICES THAT'S WHAT
THIS BUDGET PROPOSES TO DO IN
THE FACE OF ONE OF THE WORST
ECONOMIC HIPS TO OUR STATE OUR
NATION AND OUR GLOBAL COMMUNITY.
FRIENDS THIS BUDGET ALSO
INCREASES OUR ABILITY TO
SUPPORT CAL FIRE WHEN OUR WILD
FIRE CRISIS A REFLECTION OF THE
CLIMATE CRISIS CONTINUES TO
LOOM OVER US. WE HAVE A RECORD
EARLY FIRE SEASON IN MY
DISTRICT WE'VE HAD FIRES IN BIG
SUR IN SANTA BARBARA IN. IN MY
COLLEAGUES DISTRICT IN SAN LUIS
OBISPO COUNTY IN THE SANTA CRUZ
MOUNTAINS AND WHAT THE VERY
EARLY STAGE THIS BUDGET
ANTICIPATES THAT CRISIS IN
INCREASES SUPPORT FOR CAL FIRE
AS IT HAS SUPPORTED. MORE
PREVENTION AND MITIGATION IN
OUR FIRE BUDGETS. THIS BUDGET
ALSO SEEKS. TO PROTECT OUR
CLEAN AIR COMMITMENTS ARE CLEAN
WATER COMMITMENTS. IN OUR
COMMITMENTS TO HANDING OFF A
PLANET TO OUR CHILDREN AND
GRANDCHILDREN IN FUTURE
GENERATIONS WHO IF WE DON'T
STEP TWO NOW. IT'LL BE TOO LATE.
AND I PERSONALLY THINK THE
COVERT NINETEEN CRISIS MAY BE
AN EARLY WAKE UP CALL. AS WE
SEE THE ADVERSE IMPACTS IN THE
HEALTH SECTOR THE VIRUS WILL
INFECT ANYONE. BUT THE IMPACTS
ARE HITTING AFRICAN AMERICANS
LATINO COMMUNITIES. AND WAGE
WORKERS DEEMED ESSENTIAL MORE
THAN OTHES WHO CAN WORK FROM
HOME. WHO CONSUME THEIR LIVES
IN KEEP GETTING PAYCHECKS. THIS
BUDGET. LOOKS TO ADDRESSING THE
IMMEDIATE HEALTH CRISIS. IN SIX
TO PROTECT THE PRECAUTIONS WERE
TRYING TO TAKE TO PROTECT OUR
ENVIRONMENT TO PROTECT CLEAN
AIR STANDARDS CLEAN WATER
STANDARDS IN NOT. SEE THIS IS
AN OPENING TO REDUCE HARD
FOUGHT PROTECTIONS TO REDUCE
FUNDAMENTAL ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTIONS WHICH ONCE AGAIN
THE INTERSECTION BETWEEN
COVERED. IN OUR ENVIRONMENT IS
THAT ENVIRONMENTAL RACISM.
SHOWS THAT THESE IMPACTS IN OUR
ENVIRONMENT OF FACT LOW INCOME
MINORITY COMMUNITIES TO A
GREATER EXTENT THAN OTHER
COMMUNITIES. SO FRIENDS I WILL
CAST MY LAST BUDGET VOTE
PROUDLY FOR THIS BUDGET.
RECOGNIZING THE CHALLENGES AND
THE SACRIFICES WE'VE ALL HAD TO
MAKE FUNDING WE WOULD HAVE HOPE
TO GET FOR OUR DISTRICTS AND
FOR WAR THE PROJECTS I OUR
DISTRICTS. BUT WE'RE MAKING THE
BEST OUT OF A BAD SITUATION
COLLEAGUES I URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
MINING SENATOR WILK YOU HAD%
YOUR MIKE UP YOUR GOOD
EXCELLENT SENATOR TORONTO.
HELLO THANK YOU AND CHAIR THIS
IS MY SECOND YEAR. IN THE
SENATE AND THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE- WE GET HIT WITH THIS
PANDEMIC. AND THE PANDEMIC BEEN
AS A RESULT OF THE DECISIONS
EVERYBODY WE ALL HAD TO MAKE.
BECOMES ONE OF THE WORST
ECONOMIC MOMENTS- IN OUR
LIFETIMES FOR SURE. WHEN I SAW
THAT THIS WAS GOING TO RESULT
THE- BUDGET WOULD RESULT IN A
FIFTY FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
SHORTAGE. IT WAS THE QUITE SO
BRING TO TRY AND THINK HOW IN
THE WORLD ARE WE GOING TO DEAL
WITH THIS. SO I'M VERY
GRATEFUL. TO OUR BUDGET CHAIR
MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES.
I AM VERY GRATEFUL TO THE PRO
TEM TO THE STAFF TO OUR
LEADERSHIP. FOR THE WAY THAT
THEY APPROACHED THIS BUDGET THE
BUDGET NEGOTIATIONS. MANY CUTS
WERE PROPOSED THAT WERE JUST
DOWNRIGHT CRUEL. THEY WERE
CRUEL TO OUR SENIORS
THREATENING TO FOR THEM TO LOSE
THEIR DAY SERVICES. CRUEL TO
THE EDUCATION OF OUR CHILDREN
AND OUR YOUTH. CRUEL TO MEN
WOMEN AND CHILDREN WHO LIVE IN
POVERTY. AND MOST OF THOSE CUTS
OVERWHELMINGLY WERE STOPPED. ON
A DIFFERENT CHORUS AND A
DIFFERENT MODEL WAS USED TO
ADDRESS THIS TERRIBLE TIME IN
OUR ECONOMY. ONE OF THOSE WITH
TO ADDRESS MEN AND WOMEN WHO
LIVE IN POVERTY AND SOMETIMES
EXTREME POVERTY. BUT WILL WORK.
THE WORK FOR A LIVING. THIS-BUDGET ATTEMPTS TO INCLUDE ALL
CALIFORNIANS FOR ALL OF THEIR
CONTRIBUTIONS. SENATE ATTEMPTS
TO SAY TO GOOD EMPLOYERS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WORK IS GOOD EMPLOYERS WHO
RESPECT THE LAWS GOOD EMPLOYERS
TO PAY GOOD WAGES AND GOOD
BENEFITS. BUT IT ALSO SAYS TO
THOSE EMPLOYERS WHO ARE NOT
LIVING UP TO THEIR
RESPONSIBILITIES. WHO ARE
BREAKING THE LAW ON WHO ARE
CHEATING. THAT YOU HAVE TO YOU
GOTTA CHANGE YOUR EVIL WAYS. IN
LA ALONE LOS ANGELES ALONE ON A
WEEKLY BASIS THIS TWENTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS IN WAGE THEFT.
A LOS ANGELES ALONE TWENTY SIX
TO PROPOSE IN OUR BUDGET THAT
THERE BE COMPLIANCE WITH GOOD
LABOR LAWS I THINK IS THE LEAST
THAT WE COULD DO FOR THOSE OF
MEN AND WOMEN WHO WORK SO HARD.
I HAVE TALKED OF NOT ONLY
FARMWORKERS I'VE TALKED TO
GARNER WORKERS. NUMBER WORKERS
YOUR AVERAGING FIVE DOLLARS AN
HOUR HERE IN CALIFORNIA. FIVE
DOLLARS AN HOUR. RESTAURANT
WORKERS CONSTRUCTION WORKERS
FARMWORKERS YOU CAN GO ON AND
ON AND ON. THEY DESERVE WHAT
THEY SHOULD GET FOR THE HARD
WORK THAT THEY DO FOR THIS
ECONOMY FOR THE STATE. SO
BECAUSE OF ALL OF THE- I DON'T
AGREE WITH EVERY SINGLE THING
IN THIS BUDGET. BUT I DO THINK
THAT IT IS A TEMPLATE. BUT WE
IT'S NOT OVER AND THAT WE
SHOULD CONTINUE TO WORK IN THIS
DIRECTION NOT IN THE DIRECTION
THAT WE WERE FIRST ASKED TO
CONSIDER. I WILL ABSOLUTELY
VOTE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BUDGET
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
DURACELL SENATOR MCGUIRE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT IN
MEMBERS- I DON'T TYPICALLY GET
UP. ON THE FLOOR TO TALK AND-
WE'LL JUST HAVE A FEW WERE TO
SAY THAT A PRESIDENT AND I WANT
TO FIRST START OUT BY SAYING
THANK YOU TO. THE CHAIRMAN OF
THE BUDGET COMMITTEE MADAM PRO
TEM AND ALL THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE MEMBERS IN THE BUDGET
TEAM IN THE SENATE FOR ALL
THEIR WORK THAT THEY'VE DONE
OVER THESE PAST MANY MONTHS. AT
THIS IS NOT A BUDGET THAT ANY
OF US EXPECTED IT IS A BUDGET
THAT WE INHERITED IN TOGETHER
WE'RE GONNA GET THROUGH THIS.
BUT I WANNA ADDRESS A FEW ITEMS
THAT WERE DISCUSSED ON THE
FLOOR TODAY. SO WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT THE MAJORITY PARTY IN HIS
THE MAJORITY PARTY STAND UP FOR
THE VALUES OF CALIFORNIA.
ELECTED JUST QUICKLY TOUCHING.
WHILE THE MAJORITY PARTY CAN
ALWAYS DO BETTER IN THE
MAJORITY PARTY CAN ALWAYS WORK
HARD. THE MAJORITY PARTY HAS
THE LARGEST. MARGINS IN BOTH
LEGISLATIVE HOUSES IN DECADES.
EVERY CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICERS
REPRESENTED BY MAJORITY PARTY.
WHY IS THAT. WELL BECAUSE THEY
REPRESENT THE VALUES OF
CALIFORNIANS. VALUES OF
CALIFORNIANS. IN THIS JUST BE
CANDID WE'RE GONNA BE CAN'T IN
THIS BUDGET CONVERSES. THE
MAJORITY OF COMMERCE THE
MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIANS HAVE
REVOLTED. EVERY VOTED AGAINST
THE MINORITY PARTIES. THE
MORNING MINORITY PARTY'S AGENDA
ON THE FEDERAL LEVEL. SO LET'S
TALK ABOUT OUR COMPANY.
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA WAS
ALWAYS IN THE TOP THREE IN JOB
GROWTH IN FACT NUMBER ONE FOR
QUITE SOME TIME. 25% OF
AMERICA'S GROSS DOMESTIC
PRODUCT DOESN'T COME FROM
KENTUCKY. INDIANA NEVADA IT
COMES FROM THE GOLDEN STATE
CALIFORNIA. WHO HAS THE FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD
YOU DON'T HEAR ABOUT THAT. IT'S
CALIFORNIA. LARGER THAN GREAT
BRITAIN. WHO HAD THE RECORD LOW
EMPLOYMENT RECORD LOW
UNEMPLOYMENT. FOR THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS CALIFORNIA. THE
MEDIAN INCOME FOR THE UNITED
STATES FOR A FAMILY IS FIFTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS IT'S
SIXTY FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
THE GOLDEN STATE WE DON'T HEAR
ABOUT THAT SIXTY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS. THE NINE BAY AREA
COUNTIES THE NINE BAY AREA
COUNTIES. WERE ITS OWN. FEDERAL
CONNIE IT HAD THE NINETEENTH
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD.
WHY ARE WE TALKING ABOUT THAT
TODAY. THE NINETEENTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD. THANKS TO
THE VOTERS WHO REPRESENT THE
VALUES OF THE STATE WE HAD A
NINETEEN POINT FOUR BILLION
DOLLAR RAINY DAY FUND. WE PAY
DOWN SIX BILLION DOLLARS IN
PURRS DEBT OVER THE LAST THIRTY
SIX MONTHS WE PAY DOWN FIVE
POINT TWO BILLION IN STIRS DEBT
STATE TEACHERS RETIREMENT
SYSTEM DEBT. OVER THE LAST
THIRTY SIX MONTHS IS THAT
ENOUGH ABSOLUTELY NOT. BUT
THAT'S BEEN LED BY THE MAJORITY
PART. WHEN WE LET'S KEEP
TALKING ABOUT SCHOOLS. IT'S
SHAMEFUL THAT CALIFORNIA WAS
DEAD LAST YES EIGHT YEARS AGO
IN THE NATION BEHIND
MISSISSIPPIAN PER PEOPLE
SPENDING. THIS YEAR RECORD
LEVELS MANY RECORD LEVEL IN
SPENDING. ON A K. TWELVE PUBLIC
SCHOOLS IS IT ENOUGH HELL NO WE
MUST GO FURTHER. BUT IS
MAJORITY PARTY THAT IS STOOD
STRONG FOR THAT PUSH THAT
FORWARD THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FOR C. D. TEN THOUSAND
MORE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SLOTS FIVE THOUSAND
MORE SLOTS AT THE UC'S. WE TALK
ABOUT INCOME INEQUALITY IT'S
NEVER BEEN GREATER IN THIS
NATION IN HERE IN THE GOLDEN
STATE. THANKS TO THE MAJORITY
PARTY MEMBERS IN THIS. IN THIS
HOLLOW GROUND. WE FOUGHT FOR
THE LARGEST EQUAL PAY LAW IN
AMERICA IS STRONG CASE EQUAL
PAY LAW IN AMERICA AND THAT'S
IMPORTANT BECAUSE TWO THIRDS OF
MINIMUM WAGE EARNERS IN THE
STATE. ARE WOMEN. WE'VE
EXPANDED HEALTH CARE FOR THE
MOST VULNERABLE. WE'VE INVESTED
RECORD AMOUNTS IN HOMELESSNESS
AND HOUSING WE HAVE A LONG WAY
TO GO MEMBERS. BUT IT'S NOT
GOING TO BE BALLING. INSULTS
BACK AND FORTH IS ABOUT WORKING
TOGETHE ESPECIALLY IN THESE
CHALLENGING TIMES. WE'RE
STANDING STRONG FOR IMMIGRANTS
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA WILL BE ONE
OF THE FIRST MAJORITY MINORITY
STATES IN THE NEXT DECADE. AND
IT'S TIME FOR ALL OF US TO WAKE
UP. WAKE UP AND COME TO THAT
POINT. NINE IN THE RIGHT HERE.
I'M VERY CONCERNED ABOUT HOW
POLITICAL HOW POLITICAL THIS
NATION HAS BECOME. ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY I AM SUCH A PROUD
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA STATES
IN IS BECAUSE WE CAN WORK
TOGETHER BUT THERE'S A GOOD
SENATOR FROM ORANGE COUNTY.
GOOD SENATOR FROM SAN DIEGO. WE
WORK TOGETHER TO BE ABLE TO GET
AS MUCH AS WE CAN DOWN FOR
CALIFORNIA. THE ONE THING I'LL
JUST SAY IS WELL WE MAY HAVE
DISAGREEMENTS ON THIS BUDGET.
WE GOT TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
REDOUBLE OUR EFFORTS HERE TODAY
IN THE MONTHS TO COME TO BE
ABLE TO GET THROUGH. THE
CHALLENGING MONTHS AHEAD. THE
LAST THING THAT CALIFORNIANS
WANT. THIS PARTISAN BICKERING
THEY GET ENOUGH FOR THAT IN
WASHINGTON DC BUT STORAGE.
LET'S WORK TO. VERY GRATEFUL
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU CENTER
REQUIRE MEMBERS ANY FURTHER. OR
DEBATE SEEING AND HEARING NONE.
CENTER SENATOR MITCHELL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT
ON. I APPRECIATE THE KNOWLEDGE
MEANT FOR MY WORK IN THE WORK
OF THE BUDGET COMMITTEE NOW
THOSE OF YOU WHO HAVE THE HONOR
AND PRIVILEGE OF SERVING AS
CHAIR OF A COMMITTEE YOU KNOW
THE WORK IT TAKES ON TO DO THE
PEOPLE'S WORK IN TO A REVIEW
BILLSAND JUST TO DO YOUR JOB
WITH INTEGRITY THOUGHT
APPRECIATE THE TALISMAN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND LET ME PLEASE
THANK THE PUBLIC EMPLOYEES. OUR
STAFF. WHO SPEND COUNTLESS
HOURS PREPARING DOCUMENTS FOR
OUR REVIEW. LET ME BE CLEAR
DOCUMENTS FOR OUR REVIEW
BECAUSE WE ARE THE DULY ELECTED
MEMBERS OF THIS BODY WHO ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR MAKING
DECISIONS AND TAKING THE VOTE.
I FEEL A- OBLIGATION AS CHAIR
BUDGET COMMITTEE. WHEN WE VOTE
ON THE BUDGET BILLING CHIEF.
AFTER HEARING SOME OF THE
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE TO DO TWO
THINGS. THE SEPARATE FICTION
FROM FACT. AT THE SEPARATE
PROCESS FROM CONTENT. FACT AS A
RESULT OF THE PASSAGE OF PROP
TWO TWENTY FIVE. THE BUDGET
BILL MUST BE IN PRINT FOR
SEVENTY TWO HOURS. AND SO WHILE
WE OFTEN STAND ON THIS FLOOR
AND WAX FOR FROM THE FAILED
BECAUSE THE GOOD OLD DAYS WERE
GREAT THE GOOD OLD DAYS DID
CREATE A SCENARIO WHERE YOU
WOULD COME ON THE FLOOR AND SEE
A BUDGET DOCKING TO SHOULD
DEVOTE ON. THIS BILL HAS BEEN
IN PRINT. FOR SEVENTY TWO HOURS.
THAT'S FACT. FACT THE
CONSTITUTIONAL DEADLINE OF JUNE
FIFTEENTH HAS BEEN IN EXISTENCE
SINCE TWENTY ELEVEN. LET'S TALK
ABOUT THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
PROCESS AND CONTENT. THIS IS MY
TENTH BUDGET I'VE HEARD A
NUMBER OF PEOPLE TALK ABOUT HOW
MANY BUDGET THERE HAD BEEN. AND
EVERY YEAR THERE IS A CHALLENGE
THE PROCESS. WHETHER WE HAVE A
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE THEN
THERE'S A CHALLENGE TO THE
AGENDA AND HOW THE CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE WITH DESIGNED AND RUN.
IF IT'S A BIG NEGOTIATION THEN
PEOPLE ONE BIG FIVE THAT THAT'S
A BIG FIVE PEOPLE WANT
SOMETHING NOW. AND SO SUFFICE
IT TO SAY OVER MY YEAR
EXPERIENCE. THE PRESS. WILL
ALWAYS BE CHALLENGING. I SORT
OF WANT TO SAY GET OVER IT BUT
I WON'T WHAT I WILL SAY IS THIS
YEAR WE ALL ACKNOWLEDGE WHITE
WAS A CHALLENGE IT WAS NO FAULT
OF OUR OWN. AND EVERYONE WHO
HAS THE DULY ELECTED
RESPONSIBILITY OF CASTING A
VOTE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
REVIEW THE DOCUMENTS STEP UP
AND REPRESENT YOUR CONSTITUENTS.
CONTENT WE'RE SUPPOSED TO DIG
DEEP IN DEBATE AND TALK ABOUT
WHAT'S THE APPROPRIATE USE OF
PUBLIC FUNDS. WE'RE SUPPOSED TO
HAVE CONTENT CONVERSATION
THAT'S FACT BASED. THAT MOST OF
THE NEW FUNDING THAT'S BEEN
REFERENCE HERE ON THE FLOOR
TODAY OUR FUNDING REQUIREMENTS
OF CHAPTER TWO BILLS. IF YOU
DON'T WANT TO IT IN EXPAND
STATE EMPLOYEE SERVICE TO DO
THE WORK OF THE GOVERNMENT
DON'T INTRODUCED A BILL THAT
DOES SO. EITHER CHAPTER BILL
THAT ARE LAW THAT WE ARE
REQUIRED TO THE MAKE SURE WE
HAVE THE RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO
GET THE WORK DONE THAT'S FACT
IF YOU WANT TO DATE THE
INTEGRITY OF THE BILL THAT'S
ALREADY A LAW. BIG KNOWLEDGE
THAT LET'S DO THAT SEPARATE. I
APPRECIATE IN VALUE ALL THE
IDEAS ABOUT WHAT WE SHOULD BE
DOING WAYS THAT OTHER STATES
ARE MAY BE MORE EFFICIENT OR
EFFECTIVE AND ADMINISTERING
GOVERNOR GOVERNMENT. I
APPRECIATE HEARING ALTHOUGH
TODAY OF OUR OPPORTUNITY TO
TALK ABOUT AND MAKE A DECISION
ABOUT WHAT'S BEFORE US IN SB
SEVENTY FOUR. LET'S TALK ABOUT
VALUES I THINK THAT'S FAIR. IF
YOU TRULY VALUE INVESTMENTS IN
CALIFORNIA SMALL FRAGILE. THEN
I'M NOT SURE HOW YOU CAN'T
SUPPORT A BILL. THAT KEEP DOES
INDEED KEEP ARE NEEDED VETERANS
HOME OPEN. THAT DOES CONTINUE
THE FUN THE MSF P. PROGRAM FOR
SENIORS TO KEEP THEM OUT OF
NURSING HOMES. THE DESK
CONTINUE TO FIND AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS. THE DOES CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE RESOURCES TO K. THROUGH
TWELVE EDUCATION AT THE TWENTY
NINETEEN FUNDING LEVELS. A
BUDGET THAT DOES EXPAND
CHILDCARE SLOTS FOR OUR SIN TO
WORKERS. SO THEY CAN CONTINUE
TO DO THEIR WORK A BUDGET THAT
DOES SLOTS FOR ALTERNATIVE
PAYMENT PRO. WHO QUALIFY FOR
THOSE PRO. PEOPLE WHO GO TO
WORK EVERY DAY. A BUDGET THAT
DOES PROVIDE A 5% BASE
INCREASED TO OUR INSTITUTIONS
OF HIGHER LEARNING YOU SEE AND
SEE IF YOU. CAN PROVIDE AND
MAINTAINS THE CAL GRANT AWARD
FOR LOW INCOME STUDENTS AND
PRIVATE COLLEGES. A BUDGET THAT
DOES INCLUDE. LET THAT
ELIMINATED THAT RESTORED THE
CUT THAT WAS PROPOSED IN MAY
REVISED JUST SAYS WORKERS AGAIN
HELPING THE MEDICALLY FRAGILE
STAY IN THEIR HOMES. A BUDGET
THAT DOES INCLUDE. I COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENT. TO THE SSI
PORTION OF THE SS I SS P.
ELIGIBLE IN ALL OF OUR
DISTRICTS. A VOTE AGAINST BUT-
SINCE THE MESSAGE ABOUT VALUES.
A VOTE FOR THIS BUDGET DOES
ACKNOWLEDGE YOUR SUPPORT A
PROVIDING TEN POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND
TO THE HOLES IN THE EARLY START
SPECIALIZED THERAPEUTIC
SERVICES INTO DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS AND INDEPENDENT LIVING
SERVICES WITHIN OUR DEPARTMENT
OF DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES. A
VOTE FOR THIS BUDGET
TECHNOLOGIST SAVINGS OF ONE
POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS
THANKS TO THE M. C. O. TAX. A
VOTE FOR THIS BUDGET. PROVIDES
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO PROVIDE
HEARING AIDS TO CHILDREN WHO
DON'T QUALIFY FOR MEDICARE. A
VOTE AGAINST THIS BUDGET IS A
VALUE STATEMENT. A VOTE FOR
THIS BUDGET MAINTAINS GENERAL
FUND SPENDING ON MEDICARE OUT
OPTIONAL BENEFITS WHAT THE MEDI
CAL OPTIONAL BENEFIT. DENTAL
BENEFITS OPTOMETRY. OPTICIANS
INCONTINENCE CREAMS AND WASHES
DIABETES PREVENTION PROGRAMS. A
VOTE FOR THIS BUDGET. MAINTAINS
THE GENERAL FUND SUPPORT FOR
THE CARE GIVER RESOURCE CENTER.
A VOTE FOR THIS BUDGET PROVIDES
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO
CITIES FOR HOMELESSNESS PUBLIC
HEALTH AND OTHER SERVICES TO
COMBAT COLBERT NINETEEN. ALL
VOTE FOR THIS BUDGET PROVIDES
AN ADDITIONAL THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION FOR HOMELESSNESS.
A VOTE FOR THIS BUDGET.
INCLUDES FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THE AYE BANK AND GRANTS TO
SMALL BUSINESSES. ASSISTANCE
THROUGH THEIR SMALL FINANCE.
AND SO. I APPRECIATE ALL OF
THOSE OF YOU WHO IN JANUARY HAD
BRIGHT CREATIVE IDEAS ABOUT
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS FOR YOUR
DISTRICTS I HAD THOSE IDEAS TO.
BUT LET ME BE CLEAR THERE IS NO
PORK IN THIS BUDGET. NONE OF US
GOT ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO
INVEST IN THESE INNOVATION
INNOVATIVE WONDERFUL PROGRAMS
THAT ARE CONSTITUENTS CAN USE
AND DESERVE. THIS BUDGET IS THE
BEST WE CAN DO. TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE DON'T BECAUSE EXTRA ON-DO HARM ON TO THOSE WHO HAVE
ALREADY BEEN VICTIMIZED. EITHER
ECONOMICALLY OR THROUGH THEIR
OWN PUBLIC HEALTH AS A RESULT
OF THE VIRUS. THIS IS NOT WHERE
WE THOUGHT WE WOULD BE IN
JANUARY. BUT COLLEAGUES IS
WHERE WE ARE TODAY. AND SO WE
WANT TO TALK VALUES WE WANT TO
TALK PROCESS WE CAN DO THAT. A
STATE LEGISLATORS WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO LEGISLATE AN
APPROPRIATE AND ON JUNE
FIFTEENTH WE HAVE A
CONSTITUTIONAL OBLIGATION TO
REVIEW THE SPENDING PLAN FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THE
SPENDING PLAN AND BEFORE YOU IN
THE FORM OF SB SEVENTY FOUR AND
I WOULD STRONGLY ASKED FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL BEN SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I BATES.
BATES NOW TELL I FORGES NO
BRADFORD I CUT BY ADAM. I QUE.
NO DALLY. NO DODD. HI THERE ARE
SO. I GALGIANI. I GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROW. NO HERTZBERG I
HILL. I WISH SO ON FIVE TADO I
JACK. I JONES NO LEYVA I
MCGUIRE I MELENDEZ. NO MS. HI
MONNING. I LOCK NO MORALE. NO
NIELSEN. NOW HAN. FIVE FOUR. I
ROTH. I RUBIO. I STERN. FIVE
I'M BURKE AND I WAKE HOUSE. I
WIENER. I WILK NO I WAS TWENTY
NINE NEWS ELEVEN THIS
AMENDMENTS CONCUR IN. MADAM
SEND PRO TEM IF THERE IS NO
FURTHER BUSINESS THE DESK IS
CLEAR. MADAM PRESIDENT THANK
YOU SO MUCH COLLEAGUES THANK
YOU FOR THE ROBUST DISCUSSION-
IT CERTAINLY FELT LIKE A MUCH
LONGER DAY THAN IT HAS BEEN-
LET ME JUST. SAY THAT WE WILL-
CONVENE BE IN RECESS UNTIL
THURSDAY JUNE EIGHTEENTH AT
NINE AM THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU MAYOR PRO
TEM MEMBERS THE SENATE IS
ADJOURNED AND WE WILL RECONVENE
THURSDAY AT NINE AM HAVE A
GREAT EVENING.